[Musique]
général Didier Castres bonsoir bonsoir
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
thinkerview nous sommes en direct est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement
je suis fils d'officier petit-fils
d'officier et malgré cette filiation je
pense que je suis rentré dans l'armée
non pas par mégarde mais un peu par
hasard en tout cas c'était pas c'était
pas initialement ce que j'avais envie de
faire je suis pas comme un certain
nombre de rêveurs casqués qui dès la
naissance ont une vocation définitive
tatouée sur le torse en fait au fil des
préparations militaires des rencontres
avec ces gens-là j'ai apprécié à la fois
la fraternité à la fois l'amitié à la
fois le côté
la rudesse et puis et puis l'appel du
barun et je suis rentré à Saint-Cyr
comme ça et j'y ai fait pendant la
première partie de ma carrière une
carrière tout ce qui a de plus normal ou
classique pour les officiers de ma
génération j'ai commandé des unités
opérationnelles de 30 hommes de 150
hommes de 1400 hommes je suis parti avec
en opération Côte d'Ivoire au Tchad en
Centrafrique et puis j'ai alterné comme
tout le monde les affectations en
état-major en école de formation une
carrière qui avait rien d'exceptionnel
qui était un peu la norme si ce n'est
que comme j'étais trouble de marine j'ai
eu la chance de partir en mission longue
durée deux ans en Nouvelle-Calédonie
deux ans à la Réunion et deux ans à
Djibouti
et puis voilà et puis on est en 2005 et
je suis un officier comme tous les
officiers et puis là par les hasards de
la vie
je suis appelé ou muté à l'Elysée dans
l'espèce de petit état-major qui est
chargé de conseiller le président sur
les affaires militaires les affaires
militaires au sens large la race militia
tout ce qui concerne les affaires
militaires et là c'est une véritable
renaissance pour moi je découvre ce que
c'est que l'État en tout cas appliquer
aux affaires militaires je découvre ce
que c'est que la haute fonction publique
je découvre ce que c'est que le
processus décisionnel et je découvre les
crises et la façon dont on gère les
crises et je pense que j'attrape le
virus de la crise à ce moment-là et
pendant 10 ans 11 ans je ne fais plus
que ça de 2005 à 2016 je suis
systématiquement pas au coeur comme si
jamais j'étais le seul mais dans le cœur
de la gestion de crise dès lors qu'il y
a des aspects militaires d'abord 4 ans à
l'Élysée avec les présidents Chirac et
Sarkozy
ensuite deux ans au CPCO au centre de
planification et de conduite des
opérations c'est l'espèce de centre
nerveux qui reçoit tous les
renseignements qui sont nécessaires à
l'élaboration des opérations et qui
décide de toutes les opérations pour le
chef d'état-major des armées et puis et
puis enfin comme sous-chef opération
directeur des opérations pour un grand
groupe qui est celui qui est à
l'articulation politique et militaire de
la gestion de crise voilà et là a le
temps pendant 11 ans sans éteindre mon
téléphone j'ai vécu ça et ça a été pour
moi une véritable
révolution de comprendre ça de
comprendre ça et donc les crises
je sais pas si j'ai été bon dans la
résolution des crises en tout cas je
sais que j'ai été passionné à ça et ça a
duré jusqu'en 2018 et en 2018 j'ai été
touché par la plus grande injustice du
statut militaire c'est la limite d'âge
et la limite d'âge elle vous dit que
c'est plus votre tour et que vous partez
et je suis parti j'ai rejoint un cabinet
de conseils qui s'appelle l'addit qui
dirigée par Philippe caduc et hormis
c'est c'est ces missions opérationnelles
dans ce cadre là j'essaie non pas de
témoigner non pas de pardon de
transmettre parce que transmettre ça
voudrait dire que je détiens une vérité
mais de témoigner de ce que j'ai vécu
pendant ces toute cette carrière mais
principalement pendant ces 11 dernières
années
voilà pas mal comme présentation
j'aimerais qu'on parle de la
planification j'aimerais qu'on parle de
l'anticipation des crises avant la
gestion de crise
on a un proverbe qu'on cultive dans
l'équipe qui est on a le droit de perdre
mais on n'a pas le droit de se faire
surprendre c'est pas de vous non
c'est pas de vous c'est pas exactement
ça mais l'esprit est là celui qui a dit
ça il s'appelle Frédéric Legrand et il
dit il est pardonnable de perdre mais il
n'est pas pardonnable d'être surpris et
donc c'est peut-être Sky mais c'est
aussi un peu Frédéric Legrand
et donc
comment on fait pour éviter de se faire
surprendre
alors je vais répondre à cette question
évidemment
je pense que
on mesure pas suffisamment
l'évolution du contexte stratégique et
je pense que depuis une dizaine ou une
quinzaine d'années il est marqué par
trois dimensions et il faut intégrer ces
dimensions dès qu'on parle de
planification la première c'est que
depuis 2007 le rythme de déclenchement
de crise de niveau mondial qu'on appelle
les surprises stratégiques n'a cessé de
s'accélérer à tel point que la notion de
crise n'est plus une extrasystole du
système international c'est devenu
quelque chose de Constant et je vais
donner quelques exemples mais évidemment
Sky les cognait bien mieux que moi pour
moi ça a commencé ou en tout cas quand
je veux recenser tout ça ça commence en
2007 les subprimes tout le monde est
sidéré par ce qui se passe est-ce qu'on
pouvait l'anticiper je ne sais pas mais
c'est une surprise stratégique ensuite
en 2011 il y a les printemps arabes qui
laissent tout le monde pantois qui
aurait pu imaginer que un simple
maraîcher qui s'immole par le feu à Sidi
bouzaïd crée cette espèce de révolution
dans tous ces pays-là ou une
demi-douzaine de pays ont été
complètement bousculés pour ne pas dire
renverser par cette crise là ensuite il
y a eu l'avènement daesh 2013 il y a eu
également la crise des migrants qu'on a
été incapable d'anticiper il y a eu le
brexit et puis pour finir et puis il y a
eu le covid ces espèces de de phénomènes
qui ressemblent à un coup de baguette
magique de Harry Potter qui paralyse le
monde et puis enfin il y a eu la crise
ukrainienne quand on fait un peu
l'inventaire de ces crises si on est
d'accord sur le fait que c'est des
surprises stratégiques on peut en tirer
si on n'est pas d'accord on attend que
j'ai fini et ensuite on reprend le le
dialogue je pense qu'il y a trois
conclusions qui s'imposent
la première c'est qu'on doit s'habituer
dans tous les domaines pas uniquement
militaire d'un domaine économique dans
le domaine social dans le domaine
politique dans le domaine diplomatique
on doit s'habituer à vivre et à penser
avec une épée de Damoclès
au-dessus de la tête une épée de
Damoclès d'incertitude stratégique il
faut qu'on s'oblige c'est pas la nature
de l'homme il faut qu'on s'oblige à
penser l'impensable à penser
l'impensable il faut sortir du confort
douillet de notre routine de nos
assouplissements intellectuels il faut
chercher les choses qui vont être
anormales anormales et c'est difficile
c'est difficile et là aussi je vais
citer une citation qui est amusante je
crois que c'est Machiavel qui disait ça
il disait le principal défaut de l'homme
et de ne pas imaginer l'orage par beau
temps et nous nous devons imaginer en
permanence l'orage
et c'est pas pour rien si certains pays
dont la France a fait appel à des
auteurs de science-fiction pour imaginer
des scénarios qui sont en rupture
complète avec notre façon de voir les
choses avec nos habitudes avec notre
routine je pense que les dernières
crises qu'on a connu je mets un peu à
part la crise ukrainienne mais la crise
du covid fait partie de ces crises dans
lequel on n'a pas été assez vigilant ou
assez parano en fait il faut être parano
il faut être parano il faut pas répandre
cette paranoïa mais il faut imaginer
tout ça ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose a changé le mot parano
allez-y il faut être alerte
allons-y vous avez raison il faut être
alerte en tout cas il faut sortir de nos
habitudes sortir de nos habitudes sortir
de ce qui est le mainstream sortir de ce
qu'est le mainstream et c'est difficile
aujourd'hui parce qu'on est abasourdi
assommé par le mail
le deuxième point qu'il faut prendre en
compte dans l'évolution du contexte
stratégique à mon sens
c'est
le retour de la force le retour de la
force comme levier et comme régulateur
des relations internationales et quand
je dis la force c'est pas la force
militaire c'est toutes les forces et on
voit actuellement l'emploi de la force
énergétique entre guillemets et je crois
que tout ça nous éloigne en tout cas
temporairement de ces espèces de rêve
humain normal qui est le règlement des
conflits par les voies du dialogue et de
la diplomatie c'est fini c'est fini en
tout cas ponctuellement c'est fini les
annathèmes ne suffisent pas les bonnes
intentions ne suffisent pas tous ces
pays en tout cas un certain nombre
d'entre eux recourt à la force pour
préserver pour obtenir leurs intérêts ou
pour régler pour régler leurs conflits
et puis le troisième point et puis
j'arrêterai là avant de répondre à votre
opposition à ce que je viens de dire la
troisième chose qu'il faut prendre en
compte c'est l'érosion du droit
international et c'est une chose qui est
capitale et qu'on refuse de voir
l'érosion du droit international le you
sin bellum le
USA bellum le yusin Bello le droit du
commerce
la suppression ou le retour en arrière
sur les traités de non proliférations
tout ça tout ça fait que ce droit est
contesté il est contesté pourquoi
il est contesté à mon sens parce que ce
droit c'est le droit des vainqueurs des
premiers de la deuxième guerre mondiale
et ce droit il est contesté parce que la
majorité la majorité de la population
mondiale et des pays du monde c'est pas
des gens c'est des gens à qui on a
imposé droit qui correspond ni alors
culture ni à leur niveau de
développement et ils n'en veulent pas
ils n'en veulent pas l'histoire c'est un
navet c'est un c'est quoi un navet c'est
un bouquin qu'il faut pas dire
faut que Yama
la fin de l'histoire la fin de
l'histoire c'est pas un navet en tout
cas elle s'est remis en marche je sais
pas si c'est un Avène mais en tout cas
elle s'est remis en marche donc on a
d'un côté ce droit qui est contesté par
une partie importante de la population
la Chine la Russie
une partie de l'Asie l'Afrique la
deuxième chose c'est que ce droit il est
refusé par un certain nombre de
proto-état les proto-états qui s'érigent
comme des états daesh un certain nombre
d'États narcotrafiques en Amérique en
Amérique latine et ce droit il est même
parfois érodé par ce la même qu'ils
l'ont mis en place quand ça correspond
pas à leur intérêt les américains c'est
la période Trump qui a détricoté ce dont
les États-Unis sont à l'origine car ils
en sont à l'origine et puis enfin enfin
ce droit il est sous couvrant d'un
certain nombre de nouveaux domaines qui
émergent les grands fonds sous-marins
l'espace le cyberespace dans lequel il y
a pas de droit est-ce qu'il faut un
droit c'est une autre question mais dans
lequel il y a pas de droit et donc
la conclusion de cette érosion du droit
international c'est qu'on est face à
deux mondes
il y a un monde c'est plutôt le monde
occidental qui se fait la guerre du
droit entre état occidentaux et les pays
qui sont pas les pays occidentaux qui
font la guerre au droit parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas de ce droit là et donc en
fait on assiste à une guerre interne du
droit pour les pays occidentaux et à une
guerre aux normes pour les autres pays
et c'est les normes qui vont diriger le
monde et donc on doit être très vigilant
à ce qui se passe en matière de droit et
on ne doit pas faiblir sur un certain
nombre de principes qui régissent le
droit international mais je vais
répondre à votre opposition maintenant
votre question c'était je ne suis pas
d'accord on peut anticiper l'ensemble
des crises que vous avez évoquées ces
reformuler mais ça voulait dire
sensiblement là ça
donc comment on fait pour anticiper les
crises alors mon opposition sur la crise
des subprimes dans le renseignement le
renseignement militaire il y avait
personne qui se baladaient dans les
salles de marché non personne qui
travaille sur l'énergie non sur les
révolutions arabes quand on voit le
baril de pétrole à 147,90 personnes a
fait la relation de cause à effet entre
plus de fois dans les râteliers ça se
castagne
vous aviez dit quoi derrière ensuite les
subprimes
il y a eu il y a eu les printemps arabes
il y a eu la crise de l'euro il y a eu
daesh il y a eu la crise des migrants
les migrants des mecs qui travaillent
dans le renseignement n'a jamais vu un
Mayotte il y a 10 ans non il a la PAF
oui mais les mecs qui discutent dans la
campagne dans la brousse comment ça se
passe vous l'avez pas
pour revenir l'anticipation de la crise
pour éviter d'être perpétuellement dans
les gestion de crise il faut quoi il
faut du bon renseignement des bons
analystes faut des bons décisionnaires
comment ça se passe un processus
décisionnaire le renseignement remonte
qu'il traite comment ça se traite est-ce
que celui qui traite il a plutôt envie
de dire à son supérieur ce que le
supérieur veut entendre comment ça se
passe et comment on en arrive là alors
vous me posez une question qui est
beaucoup plus large que ce que j'ai vécu
moi je peux vous parler de
l'anticipation en matière de
planification des opérations mais c'est
pas c'est masque c'est parce qu'il se
passe c'est la crise énergétique moi
j'ai aucune compétence aucune légitimité
pour vous parler de la capacité à
anticiper une crise d'énergétique bien
sûr vous vous parlez de du vecteur
énergétique donc vous êtes en train de
dire que vous planifiez une opération
mais le prisme la facette du prisme de
lecture énergétique
ça vous connaissez pas ça vous savez pas
combien vous avez de jours d'essence
vous savez si votre belligérant en face
vous coupe l'essence comment ça se passe
parce que
je pense que dans l'état dans l'état il
y a assez peu de structures qui sont
dédiées à la seule analyse et à la seule
prospective dans l'état et quand je dis
prospective c'est même la planification
ce qui est de choses différentes
prospective c'est quand même du long
terme la planification c'est sur la
période 0,50 de 2 à 5 ans il y a assez
peu de structures qui sont dédiées à ça
il y en a pas au Quai d'Orsay ou très
peu il y a le CEP le CEP ou la CAPS il y
a le CAPS il y en a je sais pas s'il y
en a au ministère de l'Intérieur le
SGDSN fait ça mais sur ordre si on lui
confie un mandat il peut le faire et en
fait le
seul ministère qui consacre des
effectifs assez importants à ces
questions d'anticipation ou de
planification c'est les armées c'est les
armées et donc notamment dans ce fameux
acronyme barbare que j'ai évoqué le CPCO
on a à peu près une trentaine
d'officiers qui sont considérés un peu
comme le sel de la terre il faut pas
qu'ils entendent ça parce que sinon ils
vont plus pouvoir sortir du CPCO donc la
mission est effectivement de réfléchir
d'envisager à partir du renseignement
qu'il recueille sur les scénarios
possibles de profil ces gens-là c'est
des gens qui sont des trois armées
de l'air et Marine c'est des gens qui
sont tous quasiment tous brevetés de
l'école de guerre donc ça fait partie
maintenant qui se réappellent maintenant
l'école de guerre et donc c'est des gens
et c'est des gens qui ont une expérience
opérationnelle dans les dans les dans
les armées dans lesquelles ils étaient
voilà psychologique c'est du genre quoi
bourlingueur pas pour la guerre rap
bibliothèque
chez nous il y a pas ça chez nous il y a
enfin chez nous est-ce que je peux dire
chez nous
on n'a pas cette distinction on a des on
a des cursus qui sont pas normés mais
dans lequel chaque officier doit passer
par des étapes des étapes qui sont des
étapes de satisfaction de commandement
d'engagement opérationnel de réflexion
dans les états majeurs de haut niveau
etc etc donc on n'a pas une filière les
rats de bibliothèques avec des grosses
lunettes qui peuvent passer 15 heures
sur le même bouquin et on n'a pas des
gens qui sont tatoués sur les biceps et
qui sont capables de faire 50 tractions
et 200 pompes c'est pas comme ça voilà
mais
cette partie du CPCO qu'on appelle le J5
join five c'est les gens qui sont
chargés de l'anticipation leur mission
alors vous vous dites alerte leur
mission c'est la parano et donc en
permanence il regarde le monde là où il
y a des intérêts français ou considérés
comme tels quels sont les risques quels
sont les leviers d'évolution des
situations quel serait les solutions à
apporter ou quel serait les enjeux et
quels seraient les solutions à apporter
et donc pour un certain nombre de pays
ils font ça ils font un dossier qu'on
appelle un dossier d'anticipation et une
fois qu'ils ont fini ce dossier qui
permet de se dire s'il se passe ça et ça
alors on va vers une crise alors nos
intérêts cela alors voilà la force qu'il
faudrait mobiliser pour répondre à tel
et tel objectif une fois qu'ils ont fait
ça ils rendent ça dans un grand tiroir
et il passe à un autre pays et un autre
pays et un autre pays et quand une crise
est en train de survenir ou quand ces
fameuses indicateurs précoces sont en
train de de devenir apparent on ressort
le dossier et on commence à affiner un
dossier sur lequel on a fait ce travail
préparatoire à titre d'exemple parce que
pour moi il est très illustratif
de cette capacité d'anticipation même si
jamais ça répond pas vraiment à la
question que vous évoquez Serval
[Musique]
et donc
otage sur vos tâches sur otage sur otage
pas spécialement de réaction militaire
enfin c'est une difficulté politique
c'est une difficulté médiatique mais il
se passait pas grand chose et donc
j'appelle le colonel qui est chargé de
l'anticipation je lui dis cette affaire
là ça a pas continuer comme ça un jour
on va y aller je te demande d'étudier
cette affaire-là comment on fait pour
nettoyer la drarhard desiforas pour
libérer les otages et pour nettoyer la
drague des Iforas où on savait que
c'était un peu l'industrie du terrorisme
qui se mettait en place et donc ce
colonel fait ça travaille un mois deux
mois je sais plus
et puis on fait une réunion comme
d'habitude dans lequel il présente ses
conclusions et ceci et cela etc et je me
souviens alors c'était en 2010 ou en
2011 2010 ou 2011 je me souviens qu'il
me dit quand même incroyable en
planification voilà pour faire ce que tu
as demandé il faut 2000 hommes 200
millions de mois
2000 hommes 200 millions de mois et je
passe sur les flèches rouges les flèches
bleues par au-dessus par en dessous etc
on range la planification 2011 en 2013
on déclenche l'opération servale on se
retrouve confronté à la drar des Iforas
on mène l'opération qui s'appelait
l'opération panthère et l'opération
panthère c'est deux mois 200 millions
d'euros et
2000 hommes
donc ça c'est une forme d'anticipation
c'est pas celle que vous évoquez celle
que vous évoquez elle est pas traitée au
sein de l'État major des armées elle
doit être traitée ailleurs le ailleurs
le Haier chez nous je pense que je pense
que dans les pays anglo-saxons et
notamment chez chez les Américains je
pense qu'il y a des fines tanks qui font
ça il y a des fines tangs qui sont
financés et qui font ce travail
d'anticipation en France il y a un
travail qui a été à mon sens très
intéressant qui a été réalisé par Louis
Gautier quand il était secrétaire
général de la défense et du site et de
la sécurité nationale qui s'appelle
menace 20 30 dans lequel il a recensé un
certain nombre en prolongeant des
tendances qu'il avait observées dans
lequel il a imaginé quels étaient les
facteurs de déstabilisation n'ont pas de
la France mais la société des sociétés
en 2030 avec
Louis Gauthier il était
lgdsn en
2000 jusqu'à l'arrivée du président
Macron je crois
entre ministre des Finances ou en tant
que président Macron en tant que
président Macron d'accord voilà et donc
lui lui a fait un travail que je vous
recommande que je vous recommande de
lire je n'aurais pas l'ambition d'en
faire la synthèse qui est en ligne sur
le site du lgdsn qui est très
intéressant avec tout ce qui est
allez-y revenons à l'aspect faire
phosphores et neurones est-ce que dans
nos armées il y a une facette prisme de
lecture qui est guère économique où
est-ce que c'est juste guerre panpan qui
va prendre quoi
[Musique]
j'arrive je fais exprès
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a
[Musique]
c'est pas c'est pas alors comment
répondre comment répondre complètement à
cette question je crois que les armées
sont conscientes et c'est ce qu'on
entend quasiment pas tous les jours mais
toutes les semaines de la bouche du
général burqaert qui est le chef
d'état-major des armées les armées ont
conscience d'une chose que je pourrais
résumer comme ça nous sommes passés de
53 à 4 de 1953
d'une perspective de conflit qui était
paralysé par la peur de l'holocaus
nucléaire la guerre froide locaux
nucléaire ça c'est jusqu'en 1991 pas 89
91 et puis ensuite effondrement de
l'URSS on est passé dans une période où
la gestion de crise
correspondait à des opérations de police
internationale sous mandat des Nations
Unies et qui étaient uniquement
militaires c'est les fameuses
OMP opération de maintien de la paix des
Nations Unies de 90 jusqu'à
2000 2018-2020 et maintenant on a
conscience qu'on vienne quitter cette
logique là pour passer dans une logique
qui est la logique des stratégies
intégrales les stratégies intégrales
c'est la capacité à combiner tous les
leviers de la puissance les leviers
culturels les leviers démographiques les
leviers économiques et leviers
énergétiques les leviers militaires et
leviers diplomatiques c'est ça la phase
dans laquelle on est rentré et et ça
pour l'instant les armées ce n'est pas
le rôle des armées d'être capable
d'agréger ce genre de stratégie elle
dépasse le seul le seul périmètre des
armées il faut quelque chose au-dessus
qui soit capable d'agréger tout ça
est-ce qu'il existe oui c'est en toute
en toute rigueur et au titre de notre
Constitution c'est l'Élysée qui doit
faire ça mais est-ce que l'Elysée est
capable compte tenu ses effectifs de son
organisation de faire ça
si jamais vous me laissez le temps de
divaguer un peu plus longtemps alors si
on dit vague on se met au balcon alors
on regarde ça de loin et de haut et
ensuite je répondrai précisément à vos
questions
et je vais vous parler non pas de
l'anticipation mais je vais vous parler
des crises en général et la façon dont
moi j'analyse les biais cognitifs
en gros de nous quand je dis nous c'est
pas que nous militaires c'est nous
militaires diplomate homme politique
député ONG etc et puis c'est à élargir à
mon avis aux champs occidental je pense
que quand on est face à une crise ou
quand on décide de s'engager dans la
résolution d'une crise on commet
systématiquement 5
erreurs c'est ce que j'appelle les les
péchés capitaux de la gestion de crise
les cinq péchés capitaux de la gestion
de crise le premier de ces péchés
c'est celui que j'appelle le péché du
prêt-à-porter c'est à dire quel que soit
la crise quel que soit la crise on va
plaquer sur la crise des modes de
résolution qui sont importés soit
importée du passé d'autres crises que
d'ailleurs elles n'ont pas résolu soit
un truc un truc habituel apporter notre
Atlantique ou parfois mais pas que
parfois et donc c'est quoi le
prêt-à-porter le prêt-à-porter c'est une
facilité parce que d'abord ça évite de
se poser la question sur la réalité des
racines d'une crise en fait c'est jamais
c'est jamais la violence qui est à
l'origine d'une crise la violence c'est
la conséquence de la crise politique
la violence c'est là que moi je parle
pas politique c'est la conséquence de la
crise et donc c'est quoi le
prêt-à-porter le prêt-à-porter tel que
je l'ai vu le prêt-à-porter c'est il y a
un grand méchant qui martyrise sa
population on engage une action
militaire en règle générale c'est une
puissance régionale ou une puissance qui
a une certaine légitimité on chasse on
chasse le tyran on interrompt les
combats quand il y a des combats entre
les parties ensuite on met tout le monde
autour d'une table on fait signer des
accords de paix que personne ne m'est
jamais en oeuvre ensuite on va à des
élections parce que résoudre une crise
c'est faire des élections donc voilà et
puis on parsène tout ça d'un peu poudre
de perlimpinpin non j'ai pas dit ça
arrêtez de me dire ça et on parsène tout
ça de quelques sommets internationaux
dans lequel on collecte de l'argent type
Téléthon pour pour créer ça voilà ça
c'est ça c'est le prêt-à-porter moi je
pense que c'est évidemment c'est
évidemment une erreur intellectuelle de
croire que toutes les crises pourraient
s'inscrire dans un modèle autonormé et
dans lequel il y aura une résolution de
type Excel on rentre une résolution on
appuie on a le résultat
et donc il faut du sur mesure il faut du
sur-mesure sur la crise mais quand j'ai
dit ça est-ce que j'ai été capable moi
de faire du sur-mesure quand on sait
quand on s'est engagé dans Serval est-ce
que moi je connaissais la hiérarchie
tribale des Touaregs est-ce que je
comprenais l'histoire du Mali les
Bambara à contre les Chambas contre les
sons rats etc non je pense qu'on a perdu
on a perdu cette compétence cette
compétence elle existait avant on avait
des ambassadeurs des militaires des gens
des ONG qui allaient dans le désert et
qui connaissait chaque caillou par son
prénom chaque caillou par son prénom
sous l'effet d'abord de carrière qui
sont probablement moins attractives
d'aller compter les cailloux dans le
désert que d'être à Berlin
à Pékin ou Washington on a un peu perdu
cette appétit et puis la RGPP la
révision générale des politiques
publiques et passer par là et du coup on
a perdu cette compétence
on a perdu cette compétence et on va pas
la chercher là où elle est et où est-ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui elle est dans
les fines tanks elle est dans les ONG et
c'est là qu'il faut aller chercher mais
on a un peu de mal à faire ça parce que
il y a une espèce
d'omnipotence et d'omniscient de
l'administration en France qui considère
que c'est toujours c'est toujours
difficile d'aller chercher des
connaissances ailleurs que dans son sein
voilà ça c'est ça c'est la première
chose je me suis je vous dis ça et je le
reconnais pour ce qui me concerne
je me suis rendu compte de ça quand
au déclenchement de Serval j'ai envoyé
un jeune officier au SHD au Service
Historique de la Défense pour aller
chercher toutes les archives de la
conquête du Soudan français dans les
années 1880
et donc il m'a amené des cartes des
plans des appréciations tout ce qui
manquait pour comprendre tout ce qui
manquait pour comprendre ça c'est ça
c'est le premier
le premier des péchés il faut apprendre
la crise il faut en trouver les origines
pour pouvoir espérer trouver une
solution
le deuxième deuxième péché capital et ça
je pense que tout le monde derrière son
écran on le voit c'est la trop grande
importance qu'on accorde au volet
militaire de la résolution des crises
c'est de regarder les crises avec l'oeil
sur le microscope militaire et
évidemment évidemment d'un point de vue
politique au médiatique ou médiatique
aux politiques c'est ça signifie quelque
chose quand on dit aux armées faites
décoller un avion l'avion décolle fait
appareiller un bateau le bateau le
bateau apparaît faites sauter des
parachutistes les parachutistes les
parachutistes sautent mais c'est aussi
une négation de la compréhension des
crises jamais
non c'est de la crise c'est pas de
l'armée le politique ne comprend pas ce
qu'est l'armée je vais revenir là dessus
ce qui est l'arme gardez votre question
enfin garder reprenez votre question
quand j'aurai fini parce que quand
j'aurai fini mes cinq péchés capitaux
c'est un très bon sujet sur lequel je
voudrais aussi apporter quelques
quelques idées donc
cette focale militaire cette focale
militaire dans lequel on considère que
on peut évaluer de l'évaluer de
l'évolution d'une crise au nombre de
gens qu'on a tué aux gens dedans
c'est le Body Count américain chaque
semaine on en a tué dans on en a tué
tant on en a tué temps tout ça tout ça
est aussi une façon de pas voir quelle
est la racine de la crise en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'on en a fait
l'expérience nous Français peut-être
au Sahel mais on en a fait l'expérience
collective en Afghanistan en Irak en
Syrie à gauche à droite ce critère n'est
pas un bon critère ce critère n'est pas
un bon critère en tout cas c'est pas un
critère suffisant il faut que il
participe à une stratégie comme on l'a
dit qui soit beaucoup plus globale qui
traite de la gouvernance qui traite du
développement qui traite de l'éducation
qui traite de la démographie qui traite
de l'économie etc c'est deuxième des
péchés capitaux et vous aurez vous aurez
noté que pendant les les cinq ans qui
viennent de se dérouler les éléments de
langage émanant du ministère des armées
c'était uniquement ça c'est on en a tué
et c'est vrai qu'on en a tué et c'est
vrai que on a éliminé l'équivalent du
albagdaddy avec Adnan alsaraoui c'est
vrai que on a éliminé l'équivalent de
notre
Oussama Ben Laden avec
pamokhtar belmokdar mais avec le chef
djihadiste algérien dont je retrouve
plus le nom mais c'est pas suffisant
c'est pas suffisant le troisième
le troisième péché capital
c'est
une fois que j'ai dit ça je l'ai dit
de pas comprendre que dans la grammaire
des crises il y a une règle qui est
intangible c'est la règle de
l'inconcordance des temps la règle de
l'inconcordance des temps et le temps
politique est différent du temps
médiatique qui est différent du temps
militaire qui est différent du temps du
développement et qui est surtout
différent du temps qu'il faut pour
cicatriser les plaies quand des
populations se sont déchirées entre
elles
l'inconcordance des temps et évidemment
parce que notre monde est comme ça c'est
c'est difficile de faire autrement et
évidemment on va au plus presser le plus
pressé c'est le journaliste qui tend qui
tend un micro c'est l'image de
télévision donc on focalise un peu tout
y compris le langage sur le temps
médiatique et le temps politique mais ce
qui est sûr et là je vous affirme ça non
pas en scientifique mais de façon
extrêmement formelle jamais un avion
n'ira aussi vite qu'un tweet jamais un
bateau ne pourra avoir autant d'audience
qu'un communiqué de la Présidence de la
République donc l'inconcordance des
temps c'est quelque chose qui est
important et donc un des sujets sur
lequel les armées réfléchissent et avant
c'est comment on crée cette espèce de
coucou suisse dans lequel on va réussir
à faire sans grainer des rouages de
taille différente et qui tournent à des
vitesses différentes
je pense que l'enjeu c'est la
coordination la coordination celui qui
est capable de coordonner le plus de
temps parmi les temps que j'ai évoqué
c'est lui qui est au centre de gravité
de la solution 100 de gravité de la
solution la coordination et la
concordance des temps
le troisième le troisième le quatrième
merci je vois qu'il y a des gens
attentif le quatrième
péché capital
c'est c'est de considérer que les crises
auxquelles on est confronté sont des
crises qui sont cloisonnées
géographiquement et quand les résolvant
les unes après les autres on va résoudre
l'ensemble de la crise et c'est
particulièrement vrai pour la crise
qu'on connaît maintenant depuis
depuis
1992 1992 première attentat d'Al-Qaïda
première attentat à revendiquer c'était
à Yémen au Yémen
et donc cette considérée ces crises
comme cloisonnée géographiquement en se
disant on va les résoudre les unes après
les autres et quand on les aura toutes
résolu on aura réglé le problème en fait
là aussi c'est c'est pas un non sens
c'est une incompréhension de ce que sont
ces crises de la capacité qu'elles ont à
migrer géographiquement
ou dans l'espace immatériel il est pas
temps et on parlait des services de
renseignement que beaucoup de
technologies beaucoup de chefs beaucoup
de combattants passent du Cham de la
Syrie passe du Cham à la Libye de la
Libye au Sahel et inversement on a
retrouvé on a eu des moments de Serval
ou de barkhane on a eu des interceptions
manifestants les relations qui avaient
entre les schémas somaliens et Al-Qaïda
ils échangent de la technologie ils
échangent de l'armement ils échangent un
certain nombre de choses et donc
lorsqu'on est
non pas face à une somme de crise mais
face à un système de crise il faut des
réponses système c'est extrêmement
difficile c'est extrêmement difficile de
trouver une solution système mais c'est
pourtant ça et donc on peut toujours
résoudre le problème du centre Mali si
on n'arrive pas simultanément à
l'englober dans la problématique de Boko
Haram dans la région des Trois
Frontières Tchad Cameroun Niger si on ne
règle pas le problème de l'EGS dans les
trois frontières et
d'al-qaïdaqmi dans le nord du Mali
finalement on va s'épuiser on va écoper
on va écoper indéfiniment sans vraiment
trouver la solution et puis le dernier
le dernier de ses péchés capitaux
je dis pas que c'est une faiblesse de
nos politiques je dis que c'est le
produit de notre société c'est souvent
de choisir face à une crise un effet
médiatique plutôt qu'un effet
stratégique un effet médiatique plutôt
qu'un effet stratégique la nathane la
déclaration on va éradiquer on va faire
ceci on va faire cela je dis ça je dis
ça avec une certaine gravité
et avec un peu d'émotion parce que je
pense que tous vous avez encore en tête
de ce petit gamin syrien Ilan qu'on a
retrouvé noyé sur une plage turque
et donc la plus grande émotion c'est en
parler de la communauté internationale
ce qui à mon avis était une chose
évidemment normale et donc on a créé
dans la plus grande pas précipitation
dans la plus grande urgence une
opération maritime qui s'appelle
Sofia qui s'appelait en fait
you for Med you repen force Méditerranée
qui était chargé d'éviter ça d'éviter ce
genre de drame
l'année d'après l'année d'après
le HR disait que 4500 migrants étaient
morts noyés en Méditerranée et l'année
dernière cette opération maritime elle
était sans bateau elle était sans bateau
c'est ça c'est ça que j'appelle préféré
un effet médiatique à un effet
stratégique peut-être très peut-être
ai-je voulu mais en tout cas en tout cas
ça s'est passé comme ça pour pour ce cas
là et donc là-dedans que doit faire que
doit faire les militaires qu'on doit
faire le chef d'état-major des armées
lui je pense que son rôle c'est
d'alerter sur la réalité des effets
produits c'est-à-dire il doit avoir un
dialogue avec le niveau politique pour
dire vous dites ça mais voilà réellement
ce que ça va produire et si vous voulez
produire autre chose voilà ce que ça
implique comme
comme engagement militaire financier
économique etc et puis il a à dire il a
à dire mais je pense qu'il le dit assez
régulièrement il a à dire je
n'apporterai pas la solution à cette
crise je vais permettre de d'empêcher
l'acné d'une crise je vais séparer les
belligérants je vais chasser les gens
des villes ce qu'on a fait à Serval mais
ce n'est pas moi qui est
la solution de la crise sur Serval si
jamais vous me permettez encore trois
mots
si vous me permettez encore trois mots
la fameuse cellule d'anticipation dont
je vous parlais au CPCO le J5
quand on parlait de Serval avant qu'on
déclenche Serval
évidemment on a fait des briefings il me
présentait leur truc je comprenais je
comprenais pas j'étais d'accord j'étais
pas d'accord bref il m'avait dit mon
général pour pour qu'on trouve une
solution à cette crise il y a trois
prérequis il y a trois prérequis qui si
on n'arrive pas à les satisfaire il y
aura pas de solution à la crise ça
c'était en 2012 à l'été 2012 ils me
disent le premier le premier prérequis
c'est qu'il y aura pas de solution à
l'époque la gangrène djihadiste était
concentré dans le Normandie mon général
la première de ces conditions c'est
qu'il n'y aura pas de solution sans
l'Algérie ou contre l'Algérie
première chose ça c'est quand même
c'était pas mainstream et du coup
j'étais allé voir Jean-Pierre
Chevènement qui avait toute sa tête et
qui avait été remarquablement bon
conseiller sur cette affaire merci Val
de Grâce d'ailleurs de nous l'avoir
remis sur pied remercial vous avez
raison vous avez raison et donc c'est un
des meilleurs connaisseurs d'ailleurs je
demande s'il était pas dans le
déplacement du président Macron en
Algérie il y était ou pas
donc première chose il y aura pas de
solution sans l'Algérie contre l'Algérie
on n'a pas réussi à faire on n'a pas
réussi à faire embarquer l'Algérie il y
a pas eu de solution la deuxième chose
il n'y aura pas de solution si les
belligérants ou si jamais les parties au
conflit
ne signe pas un accord de paix sincère
ils ont pas signé un accord de paix
sincère qui d'ailleurs est toujours pas
mis en oeuvre depuis 2013 et la
troisième chose la troisième le
troisième pré-requis c'est on aura pas
de solution si jamais on n'arrive pas à
fermer l'énorme canalisation qui arrive
de la Libye et qui projette dans le
Sahel de l'armement de la drogue des
combattants de l'argent de l'idéologie
etc etc et donc voilà les trois
prérequis et en fait
dès qu'on s'arrête un peu sur image et
qu'on regarde ce qu'on a fait enfin les
cinq premières années les 7 les 8 les 9
etc on se rend compte que on n'a pas été
capable
on porte pas la seule responsabilité de
tout ça mais on n'a pas été capable de
satisfaire ces trois impératifs donc on
avait anticipé on avait anticipé ce qui
était nécessaire on a cherché à le
mettre en œuvre Jean-Yves Le Drian est
allé je ne sais combien de fois en
Algérie pour rencontrer ces homologues
moi j'avais proposé aux Algériens ce qui
est quand même dans la culture militaire
française qui est quand même
exceptionnelle je leur avais proposé de
mettre un officier de liaison de l'armée
algérienne dans notre PC pour qu'il y
ait aucun doute sur nos intentions on
avait des procédures qui faisaient que
dès qu'on conduisait une opération à
moins de X kilomètres de la frontière
algérienne on les prévenait pour pas
qu'il y ait de d'ambiguïté sur ce qu'on
faisait
voilà et on n'a pas réussi tout ça pour
revenir assez péché capitaux et cette
problématique d'anticipation
question sur les
la guerre économique est-ce que la
guerre économique est modélisée dans les
scénarios de l'armée ou est-ce que c'est
juste
la guerre classique est-ce que l'aspect
je vous pose la question parce que pour
nous en termes de guerre économique un
chômeur coûte plus cher qu'un mort donc
je me pose la question si notre armée
qui est obligé de faire
qui je vais pas être vulgaire mais qui
est qui est le dernier recours du
politique quand il fait des bêtises
quand il comprend rien il envoie
c'était une bêtise ou pas pardon la
Libye c'était une bêtise il faut
demander ça à celui qui en a décidé
donc on reparlera de la Libye bien un
peu plus tard si vous voulez bien
sûr bien sûr donc l'aspect guérir
économique là on est en train de le
vivre c'est que on va vous livrer notre
notre analyse et vous allez nous
corriger vous avez peut-être la demander
vous avez peut-être touché de la tête
on a l'impression de voir des gens qui
sont pas préparés nos politiques ils
sont pas préparés ils ont rien vu venir
ils sont fait surprendre comme des bleus
et maintenant il s'agit dans tous les
sens il s'agitent les bras ils agitent
leur bouche ils font des tweets Vengeurs
et puis derrière ils se prennent des
grandes tartes parce que les gars en
face ça fait 8 ans qui bossent leur plan
avec des gars bien fâchés
où ils ont fait la modélisation à 360°
intégrale à Pessac comme vous voulez et
là ils sont tellement fâchés qui vont
nous enlevez les canines les incisives
les molaires et puis ils vont faire
durer le plaisir juste pour bien
remettre notre cas politique à leur
place donc est-ce que l'aspect guerre
économique est modélisé à l'armée non si
jamais votre question c'est mais je
pourrais je pourrais pas aller au-delà
d'une réponse un peu un peu binaire non
nous dans le domaine économique vous
rendez compte à quoi on vous laisse on
vous expose vous l'armée
je vais prendre votre défense non je
fais j'en suis ravi mais on nous expose
c'est pas
on nous expose on expose notre pays
parcecié on expose notre première ligne
quand même on est en première ligne
ok je vais faire un
bombe nucléaire de faible intensité de
tactique c'est combien de morts
tout de suite
ce truc là c'est 150000 200 ans
quel est le temps qu'il faut pour
refroidir un canon bah ça dépend et
depuis combien de temps il a tiré c'est
ça et donc ça dépend où vous tirez votre
petite bombe nucléaire ça dépend ça
dépend beaucoup de choses concentration
de population etc mais avant faible
densité on va dire faible densité
non non creuse non non non
attendez
une dévaluation de l'euro mais je pense
qu'il vous êtes trompé d'invité non
comme comment vous voulez que je sache
j'ai déjà compris enfin j'ai compris
simplement sur sur le la dimension
économique
quand on fait une planification et donc
je vous dis c'est pas de l'anticipation
c'est une planification on travaille sur
trois à cinq ans et on travaille dans la
perspective d'être engagé pour aller
promouvoir nos intérêts défendre les
ressortissants français ou ou
pas éliminer mais réduire la capacité de
nuisance d'un adversaire
et ça et donc évidemment on étudie les
facteurs économiques et on les étudie et
donc si on sait que ce pays ce pays va
bénéficier comme source de richesse
principale ou comme source
d'alimentation principale de ceci de
ceci cela c'est évidemment des objectifs
qu'on va regarder dès lors qu'ils sont
légaux dès lors qu'ils sont légaux
outils du droit de la guerre c'est un
secret pour personne que que
l'on sait et que l'on a étudié quelles
sont les principales ressources en
matière énergétique de l'Iran et que si
jamais il y avait un scénario qui
conduisait à un conflit avec l'Iran on
sait exactement ce qui lui ferait le
plus mal au point de vue économique mais
ça c'est pas la guerre économique c'est
pas vraiment ce que j'appelle la guerre
économique la guerre économique c'est
une guerre non passive oui c'est une
guerre silencieuse qui oppose des outils
économiques et ça les armées sont pas là
dedans c'est pas le rôle des armées non
c'est pas le rôle des armées nous on est
capable de dire
ça c'est important pour ce pays ça ça
sera un objectif qu'il faut préserver
pour la reconstruction après ou au
contraire qu'il faut mettre hors d'état
etc etc vous savez que pour la pour la
crise enfin pour la crise pour la guerre
la guerre contre daesh en Irak et en
Syrie
les frappes les frappes qui étaient
faites notamment par les Américains qui
ont quand même beaucoup d'avance dans ce
domaine-là les les frappes qui étaient
effectuées dans les champs de pétrole
qui était exploités par daesh une partie
de la richesse de daesh c'était
l'exportation du pétrole plutôt vers le
nord de la Syrie c'était
l'exploitation des œuvres d'art et puis
c'était la zakat c'était l'impôt l'impôt
musulman et bien quand les Américains
décidaient de ont décidé de couper les
ressources que daesh tirées du pétrole
détruisait pas par un tapis de bombe les
champs de pétrole il détruisait les
têtes d'exploitation de l'extraction du
pétrole juste la tête donc voilà on a
cette capacité là mais c'est dans
l'action et c'est dans le cadre du
conflit du conflit ouvert en matière de
guerre économique les armées sont pas
sont pas c'est pas qu'elles sont pas
concernées c'est qu'elles sont pas
impliquées et on voit pas très bien quel
rôle elle pourrait jouer quel rôle actif
elle pourrait jouer qui est censé faire
et qui est censé faire ça
les stratégies les
stratégies globales c'est-à-dire des
stratégies qui font agir plusieurs
ministères ce que nous on sait faire
bien
la terre ce que nous on sait bien faire
c'est faire travailler le Quai d'Orsay
avec le ministère des armées et un peu
avec l'intérieur ça c'est deux
ministères les deux premiers Quai
d'Orsay et armés qui se parlent depuis
très longtemps qui se comprennent il y a
des échanges il y a des réunions
permanentes donc on sait très bien faire
ça à deux ministères
on s'est un peu mieux le faire depuis
qu'il y a eu sentinelle et qu'on a été
amené à travailler beaucoup avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur pour les autres
pour les autres c'est des scénarios sur
lequel on n'a pas l'occasion de
s'entraîner on l'a fait une fois un peu
au moment de l'épidémie Ébola en Afrique
où on a été amené à travailler avec le
ministère de la Santé et un peu au mont
du covid mais c'est pas suffisant pour
être capable de mettre en place des des
stratégies interministérielles celui qui
est chargé de faire ça celui qui est
chargé de faire ça c'est le SGDSN le
secrétariat général pour la défense et
la sécurité nationale c'est l'organisme
qui est chargé de produire du consensus
entre les conduire du consensus entre
les ministères ou de produire de
l'interministérialité et produire du
consensus ça veut pas dire mettre tout
le monde d'accord ça veut dire que tout
le monde sache ce sur quoi on est
d'accord et ce sur quoi on n'est pas
d'accord c'est lui qui est chargé de
faire ça sur les sur les stratégies
intégrales ou les stratégies globales
sur lequel vous m'amener qui est un
sujet intéressant
moi j'ai participé
à partir du moment où je suis arrivé à
l'Élysée jusqu'au moment où j'ai quitté
mes fonctions à 300 conseils de défense
le fameux conseil de défense dont tout
le monde parle vrai le vrai j'ai
participé de façon directe ou indirecte
à 300 conseils de défense une centaine à
la table avec le président éliministre
et 200 quand je préparais les options
soit pour le ministre soit pour soit
pour le Sénat
dans tous ces conseils jusqu'à l'arrivée
du président Macron
c'était un conseil qui était
exclusivement militaire donc la
conclusion c'était on en met 10 de plus
on en met 10 de moins on tire là-dessus
on tire pas là-dessus etc quand il y a
eu la crise des migrants il y a eu un
conseil de défense c'était à l'époque de
deuxième crise des migrants c'était à
l'époque du président Macron donc je
regarde la liste des gens invités je
vois que le garde des sceaux était
invité je vois que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale est invitée plus
les habituels qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette affaire c'est on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir ces gens-là à ces
conseils de défense d'habitude le format
habituel c'est ministre des Affaires
étrangères ministre des Armées Premier
ministre parfois économie et finances et
puis tous les services associés et là
quand il y a des décisions ah oui non
quand il y a des décisions qui sont
nature qui sont nature économiques ou
financières
et là
madame Belloubet un conseil de défense
qui était et Jean-Michel Blanquer et
Jean-Michel Blanquer qui était présent
non mais je dis pas ça je dis on se
posait la question et donc le Conseil le
conseil de défense a lieu donc les
militaires étaient prêts à dégainer un
bateau de plus un bateau de moins ceci
cela etc renforcer Frontex ou des choses
comme ça et en fait le sujet a pas du
tout tourné comme ça le président Macron
il a posé deux questions
c'est secret défense non non il a posé
deux questions ou en tout cas
l'équivalent la première c'est quelle
est notre politique des visas
ce qui est quand même assez important
pour se poser la question de savoir
comment les migrants pourquoi les
migrants donc c'était une très bonne qui
une très bonne question d'intégrer ça à
la stratégie globale mais c'était pas la
meilleure la meilleure c'était la
question qu'il a posé au ministre de
l'éducation nationale de dire notre
politique
d'accueil de d'étudiants étrangers
qu'est-ce qu'ils font
qu'est-ce qu'ils font et Jean-Michel
Blanquer qui connaissait ça sur le bout
des ongles il dit ils font de la
philosophie du droit ils sont à la
Sorbonne etc et le président dit mais
comment voulez-vous que ces gens-là
retournent chez eux si jamais ils font
de la philosophie du droit public etc si
on veut que ces gens-là reviennent chez
eux pour développer leur pays il faut
qu'il fasse du BTP il faut qu'il soit
ingénieur ceci ingénieur cela etc et en
fait je pense ce que j'ai vu président
Chirac président Sarkozy président
Hollande que le président Macron c'est
le premier président
qui est né dans la mondialisation et qui
comprend l'interaction qui rentre tous
ces domaines est-ce qu'il a apporté une
solution j'en sais rien est-ce que
quelqu'un a apporté une solution je suis
sûr que non mais en tout cas lui il a la
compréhension de cette de cette
nécessité de mettre en oeuvre des
stratégies intégrales alors comment on
fait pour intégrer l'économie ou
qu'est-ce qu'on agrège autour de
l'économie ça ça je sais pas sur cette
affaire là sur cette affaire là je
reprends encore un exemple mais qui est
un exemple on going dans le dans le
déroulement des opérations en français
ça veut dire quoi hungry ça veut dire
dans le déroulement actuel dans le
déroulement des opérations
les Américains pour pour la Syrie
pour la lutte contre daesh parce que
pour la Syrie avait une stratégie qui
était qui était globale qui était assez
globale qui reposait sur trois ou quatre
piliers d'abord taper sur les clous avec
un gros marteau c'est habituel c'était
arrêté les filières de combattants
étrangers deuxième chose troisième chose
c'était coupé les ressources économiques
de daesh il y avait quand même de
l'argent qui promenait de l'extérieur
des dons etc et puis former former une
armée qui pourrait s'opposer à la fois à
daesh et à la fois
à Bachar el-Assad un vieux
non ils ont fait ça eux ils ont fait ça
et donc ça reste quand même un vœu un
vœu mais quand vous parlez parce que
c'est je pense que c'est c'est assez
intéressant de voir notre compréhension
à nous Français des stratégies
intégrales et donc ça c'était quasiment
au déclenchement de l'opération ils ont
sorti de plan avec toute la coalition
voilà ce qu'on veut faire etc tout le
monde a dit oui comme il y avait des
choses qui échappaient aux champs
militaires comme le fait d'interrompre
les filières les filières de combattants
étrangers couper les vivres etc c'est le
nu au niveau
interministériel donc au niveau de
l'Élysée
et puis et puis nous on a continué à
faire que taper avec notre petit marteau
sur les clous jusqu'au moment où il y a
eu l'attentat de Nice
l'attentat de Nice c'était deux ans
après deux ans ou trois ans après le
déclenchement et là et là on a dit je me
souviens de ce conseil et là il a été
dit par le ministre de l'économie et des
finances à ce moment-là si c'est comme
ça on va leur couper les vivres mais
avant on l'avait pas fait avant on
l'avait pas fait et donc on a une assez
grande difficulté à mettre en oeuvre des
stratégies interministérielles intégrées
pour un certain nombre de raisons la
culture de l'État français
le cloisonnement etc mais on a beaucoup
de mal donc sur l'économie je suis sûr
que à Bercy il y a des gens qui
réfléchissent là-dessus mais je suis sûr
si si je suis sûr que ils peuvent se
tromper
ils peuvent se tromper il y a une chose
ils vont être obligé de mettre leur plan
en route
il y a une chose quand la mère sortir
qu'est-ce qu'il y en short qu'est-ce qui
en claquette qui est-ce qui a plus de
short qui est-ce qui a raconté n'importe
quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a pas de travail
il y a une chose il y a une vent sur le
point de PIB
mais globalement
je vous donne un avis même pas de site
web enfin si un avis de citoyen je
regarde les chiffres qui nous sont qui
nous sont diffusés je constate que
l'inflation est moins importante en
France que dans le reste de la de
l'Union européenne pourquoi mais je sais
pas moi je connais pas je suis pas
tarifaire hein c'est décaler la dette
en tout cas en tout cas faire un effet
de manche du Windows dressing bon la
poudre de perlimpinpin un écran de fumée
brasser de l'air chaud c'est tout ce que
je vous ai pas laissé dire depuis le
début de l'interview
vraiment que je me chauffe bah faites
comme vous voulez
faites comme vous voulez mais sur le
champ économique je resterai non pas de
marbre mais j'ai aucune j'ai aucune
légitimité pour vous parler ça je peux
vous dire on a été agréablement sorti
surpris par le collège interra mes
défenses nouvellement école de guerre
parce que ça fait des années qui
s'intéressent à ça et ils sont
rapprochés de l'école de guerre
économique et ils ont des séminaires
ensemble et j'ai participé à un
séminaire qui réunissait l'école de
Guéret économique et l'école de guerre
alors le j'ai eu
on les connaît pas très bien mis à part
Bulot
donc l'armée française est quand même on
les a trouvés vachement proactifs et ça
nous a vachement touché et c'est pour ça
qu'on a un regard bienveillant sur nos
cordes armées parce que je vais être
vulgaire mon général mais au moins eux
ils sortent les doigts du cul parce
qu'ils sentent le sapin venir et ça ça
touche beaucoup
et revenons revenons à nos histoires de
guerre économique et de Guerlain
S comme la vôtre il y a les mêmes en
Russie
avec l'aspérus le côté
Popof le côté rue de Grizzly fait froid
il a bouffé l'effondrement de 90 il sort
rappelle bien la guerre économique qui
sait ce que c'est
quel jugement vous portez sur la
politique de la France dans la gestion
de la guerre avec la Russie parce que là
on entend nos politiciens qui sont ils
sont en train de nous faire un peu
d'huile sur leur siège en cuir à dire
non non non on n'est pas en guerre on
n'est pas en guerre
alors qu'on est en guerre on est en
guerre économique ouverte pleine Vannes
on a nos élites un peu la bouche en
canard alors les sanctions on était
peut-être un peu précoce sur le tout de
suite dégainé tout de suite ils
connaissent pas les Russes on a trois
pauvres soviétologues
qui font perdurer leur prisme de lecture
comment vous jugez
qui se passe en ce moment en termes
proactif d'anticipation de réponse de sa
jugement là on était prêt pardon on
était prêt
non il ne manquez pas
d'avoir une équipe qui rentrait de
vacances et qui s'est fait un petit peu
surprendre
la politique de la politique de la
France ce que ce que je pense
au-delà en deçà ou au delà du seul cas
russe je peux que sur le Carrus bon je
pense non mais je pense que
la politique des sanctions
en Afrique du Sud en Afrique du Sud
l'Iran le Soudan de Béchir etc ça n'a
jamais rien produit ça puni en tout cas
ça n'interrompt pas en tout cas la
politique de sanction ça n'interrompt
pas une agression aussi abominable
soit-elle ça ne ça ne chasse pas
immédiatement les gens qui dirigent le
pays qu'on veut punir ça punit la
population et ça la punit à long terme
ou pendant longtemps en tout cas ça n'a
pas d'effet je pense que je pense que le
recours au sanctions c'est l'espèce de
joker quand on veut rien faire on peut
plus rien dire non on peut rien dire
c'est à dire on se dit bah on peut pas
rester sans rien faire qu'est-ce qu'on
veut faire non on veut pas le faire donc
on des sanctions
et puis on se congratule on dira ça non
en tout cas les sanctions c'est
c'est plutôt une façon de dire à
l'opinion publique et à l'opinion
internationale et dans le champ
diplomatique on fait quelque chose mais
pas trop sur la guerre en Ukraine sur la
guerre en Ukraine la guerre russes en
Ukraine moi la chose qui qui m'a le plus
étonné
c'est
la rapidité et la répétition du fait que
on n'irait pas en guerre on n'irait pas
en guerre je pense que non mais ça j'ai
trouvé ça j'ai trouvé ça quand même
pas très c'est pas très honorable en
disant ah mais c'est pas le temps mais
c'est pas le temps donc on sera pas en
guerre et on l'a dit répéter professé
tout le monde l'a dit les Américains
tous les pays de l'Union européenne je
pense que cette façon d'expliquer ou de
dire directement un Poutine que on
n'irait pas aussi loin que c'est quand
même c'est quand même pas quelque chose
qui manifeste notre attachement au
principe de fonctionnement de l'opinion
du système des relations internationales
donc on l'a dit à chaque fois on l'a dit
à chaque fois est-ce que est-ce qu'il
aurait fallu envoyer un avertissement
d'une autre nature au président Poutine
à un moment au début pour dire attention
pas trop loin quand même
je pense que ça a été envisagé je pense
que je suis même sûr que le CPCO ça me
CPCO
oui je sais pas quoi je peux pas vous le
dire c'est c'est maintenant extrêmement
gardé mais
peut-être que dans les options je pense
enfin je pense que quelqu'un a bien dû
dire si vous trouvez qui va trop loin si
vous voulez donner un avertissement et
on pense que ça déclenchera pas le low
cosmucléaire nous on vous donne le moyen
de couler le mozza
ukrainisé je crois moderniser
donc donc voilà il y a des options
je pense qu'on a on a été un peu je sais
pas si on rentrait de vacances mais on a
été
terrorisé surpris surpris il est
pardonnable d'être battu pas d'être
surpris on a été surpris et on était
surpris
parce que depuis 2014 depuis avant 2014
chez moi vous l'avez d'ailleurs vous
l'avez vous l'avez
écoutez ici j'ai trouvé ça d'ailleurs
remarquable même si vous l'avez beaucoup
embêté Védrine
monsieur Védrine qu'on ne peut pas
soupçonner d'être un
avait annoncé depuis longtemps que on
était sur on était sur une pente
savonneuse et depuis 2014 oui mais même
avant même avant donc ça veut pas dire
qu'il fallait pas le faire mais ça veut
pas dire qu'il fallait pas le faire mais
ça veut dire que c'est compliqué d'être
surpris à partir du moment où on avait
décidé ça qu'on avait posé ça etc donc
je pense que on a choisi l'option
l'option on n'est pas content c'est pas
bien mais on fait rien ou en tout cas on
a trouvé cette espèce d'accord avec
Poutine sans monter aux extrêmes d'armée
puissamment on collectivement d'armée
puissamment l'Ukraine en regardant ce
qui se passe
c'est pas un accord ça non un accord
c'est c'est Poutine à accepter sans
monter aux extrêmes que on donne de
l'armement à l'Ukraine et nous c'est ce
qui va nous arracher les dents une par
une juste derrière je sais pas ça lui
donne un prétexte quand même je sais pas
moi je connais pas suffisamment vous
savez on parlait de prêt-à-porter de sur
mesure moi je connais pas suffisamment
la société russe j'ai des amis qui ont
des efforts des enfants en Russie
enfant qui sont mariés avec des Russes
qui travaillent à Moscou etc c'est quand
même
je pense qu'il y a quand même une
tension assez forte alors il y a une
partie de la Russie qui est complètement
sous contrôle on dit que tous les gens
qui viennent combattre c'est quand même
des gens qui arrivent de Sibérie de ce
site cela etc c'est pas les Moscovites
de Moscou donc il y a un climat qui est
pas aussi certain que ça sur le fait
qu'il va nous arracher les dents les
unes après les autres pendant longtemps
je parlais chez les dents économiquement
j'ai compris j'ai compris mais je suis
pas sûr que cette guerre soit
supportable très très très très très
longtemps par par les Russes
attendez qu'on passe l'hiver
prochain parce que là là ça va être un
hiver qui va être encore un petit peu
doux on a 95% de notre stock de gaz il y
a EDF qui est en train de s'activer à
fond pour nous remettre des réacteurs
opérationnels mais l'hiver 2023 quand on
mangera à la paille nos pâtes à l'eau
froide
j'en sais rien moi j'en sais rien je
suis pas capable d'estimer ça je pense
que on est quand même capable dans notre
pays il y a quand même des gens qui sont
capables de modéliser ça de dire combien
de dire pour pour tenir l'hiver 2022
faire un stock de masque
vous pouvez pas dire ça comme ça
pourquoi je peux pas dire ça la gestion
de crise covid parce que on parle de
gestion de crise nous nous on a ce
scanner à peu près toutes les
administrations au moment où ils étaient
en train de courir comme des poulets
sans tête
et les deux seuls endroits on a été
vraiment on a été fiers et vous savez
cette quand vous êtes fier de façon
patriotique là vous touchez le cœur oh
merci un EDF
EDF vous savez pourquoi parce que eux
avant tout le monde ils étaient prêts et
puis n'hésitez-p
[Rires]
le reste pas de stock de masque on
envoie dans les DOM-TOM des stocks de
masques pourris on a une communication
étatique qui crée plus de séquelles de
cicatrices dans l'opinion publique
qu'autre chose il faut pas porter les
masses il faut porter les masques moi je
sais pas comment on met un masque vous
comprenez on fout 10.000 euros de prune
ou pharmacien qui ont des masques
c'était une façon de couvrir notre
incompétence notre incurie
là vous me dites qu'il y a des gens qui
sont en train d'anticiper ou qui ont
déjà anticipé ce qui est en train de se
passer
ça fait 15 ans qu'on fait de la
géopolitique et de l'anticipation on les
regarde on les regarde franchement alors
on doit se tromper on s'avance peut-être
un peu on les regarde on a l'impression
de voir des touristes des Satanis
touristes même pas un climaté allant à
la plage sans crème solaire sans parasol
sans Bob mais avec des bois canards
ouais ouais ça s'appelle la signature de
la dette française
le carnet de chèques de Mamie vous savez
vous l'avez vous avez un certain nombre
de choses je vais pas si difficile à
entendre ça c'est pas
face caméra face caméra comme je dois
être soumis aux devoir de réserve non
mais voilà comme citoyen évidemment qui
a un certain nombre de choses que qui
sont qui sont tout à fait
incompréhensibles qui sont de
l'amateurisme qui sont qui sont la
maturisme ou
cette incapacité à se projeter à
imaginer des scènes de rupture
imprimante 3D moi je peux vous dire
qu'il y a des gens qui réfléchissent sur
les conséquences de de
l'industrialisation de de l'imprimante
3D alors nous on y trouve des intérêts
on va plus se balader avec des pièces
très lourdes très embêtantes à
transporter on va les faire sur place
quand on sera en opération mais il y a
plein de scénarios de rupture avec ça
mais au-delà de ça
et c'est pas pour les excuser j'excuse
personne et j'ai pas habilité à excuser
qui que ce soit au-delà de ça moi je me
souviens une chose que j'ai que je pense
vrai c'est ce que dit ce que dit toc
ville dans la démocratie en Amérique
Tocqueville il dit les démocraties
d'opinion sont incapables de stratégie
persévérance
les démocraties d'opinion sont
incapables de stratégie
persévérante moi je ne fais que citer
Tocqueville et je suis pas un
spécialiste mais je constate que ceux
qui ont des stratégies bonne ou
mauvaises critiquables ou pas c'est des
pays non sauf les États-Unis c'est des
pays non démocratiques c'est la Chine
c'est la Russie la Chine ils ont ils ont
élu un nouvel empereur pour je sais pas
combien de temps Poutine c'est 2036
Poutine c'est 2036 et c'est l'Iran et
c'est la Corée du Nord et c'est ces
pays-là je dis pas que ce sont des
bonnes stratégies qui sont capables de
ça nous notre démocratie
démocratie politique notre alternance
tous les cinq ans etc elle fait que on
est capable de changer on est capable de
changer très très rapidement de pieds et
de stratégie ce qui est assez étonnant
c'est que les Américains qui changent
qui peuvent changer de majorité
politique tous les quatre ans et pas
tous les 5 ans eux il y a quand même une
constante
il y a une constante c'est tout le monde
de défense le Pentagone
industriels d'armement l'ouverture des
marchés et repousser et
donc nous nous il y a aussi
il y a aussi notre culture notre culture
politique française on élit un président
où on élit on élit des responsables et
deux ans après on veut qu'il s'en aille
ah bah là c'est sûr que c'est en deux
ans on n'est pas on met pas une
stratégie en place et pour en revenir
aux crises parce que c'est quand même
plutôt là que je suis
[Musique]
le plus à l'aise
je crois que quand on décline un peu les
fameux péchés capitaux voilà les trois
quatre points sur lequel nous on doit
faire un effort d'abord je pense que en
matière de stratégie ou d'objectif à
atteindre dans une crise il faut être
lucide sur notre capacité à changer les
choses il faut être lucide il faut
arrêter de dire il faut dire ce qu'on
est capable de faire ce qu'il faut
prendre réellement conscience que la
France est devenue une puissance de
moyenne impuissance non
c'est pas ça c'est ce truc là c'est
il faut pas prendre conscience il faut
être lucide sur les effets que nous
avons dans la résolution des crises je
prends deux exemples qui sont militaires
mais moi il fait venir pour ça
quand on était engagé en Afghanistan
quand on était engagé en Afghanistan et
dans les conditions très difficiles où
on était dans la capitale
on pesait la France pesait
2,5% des effectifs de la coalition
emmenée par les Américains et elle
s'occupait d'une partie du territoire
afghan qui correspondait à 3,5%. quand
on était en Syrie en Irak on a on a
engagé des choses extrêmement
importantes les forces spéciales des
chasseurs etc on représentait
2,5% des moyens aériens qui étaient
déployés et les américains ils
représentaient
96%. quand vous êtes au conseil
d'administration et que vous pesez
2,5%, c'est pas vous qui faites la
stratégie et donc est-ce qu'on est un
pays de moyenne impuissance il faut être
lucide sur le fait que nous on pèse 2,5%
de la coalition en Afghanistan ou 3,5 et
2,5% de la coalition en Syrie et donc
c'est pas un moyen d'impuissance c'est
ça
c'est il faut voir les choses comme
elles sont
[Musique]
quand on a apporté la démocratie pour
les petites filles
de ce que je voulais dire Siri
non arrêtez de sculpter du ventre
il faut être lucide
lucide sur ce que l'on pèse et lucide
sur les objectifs qu'on se fixe dans une
crise en fait de façon extrêmement
louable dès qu'on s'engage dans une
crise dans la résolution d'une crise
notamment quand on s'engage
militairement diplomatiquement etc en
gros on a comme objectif de transformer
tous les pays dans lequel on s'engage en
quand on Suisse quand on Suisse point de
vue de la propreté le riz la démocratie
la démocratie la propreté le
développement économique l'ordre etc non
c'est pas ça il faut il faut qu'on soit
capable de se dire quel est l'effet ou
quel est l'état final qu'on recherche je
peux vous couper
donc je finis et ensuite vous allez me
reprendre donc la lucidité sur ce qu'on
est capable de faire et sur l'ambition
qu'on se fixe ensuite il faut un peu de
patience pour laisser les stratégies
produire leurs effets on n'est pas sur
un jeu vidéo on peut pas passer de la
phase 1 à la phase 4 donc il faut avoir
cette patience il faut que tout le monde
et cette patience
les militaires bien sûr
l'État les parlementaires qui doivent
être le relais de cette décision et le
peuple français et puis ensuite il faut
la résilience il faut la résilience de
ce que ça va coûter
de ce que ça va coûter envie en argent
etc etc la lucidité la patience et là et
la résilience et ça c'est quand même pas
des qualités que on
met au fronton des démocraties d'opinion
ou quand on voit ça un jour 80% en
pensent ça le lendemain 80% en France ça
quand on voit comment s'est passé le
départ d'Afghanistan je dis pas qu'il
fallait pas partir d'Afghanistan le
départ le départ des Français non le
départ des Français on est parti en 2013
en 2007 non on est parti en 2008 mais ça
c'est ça c'est fait on s'est engagé on a
eu quand même un certain nombre de morts
en Afghanistan je pense qu'on a été
d'abord on a nos soldats ont été
courageux ils ont fait le job on s'est
montré jusqu'à là un allié solide des
Américains et c'est une campagne
électorale et c'est la 49e proposition
du Hollande 49e proposition du candidat
Hollande sur 50 ça montre la priorité
qui a dit l'hiver Noël 2012 il y aura
plus de français en Afghanistan
est-ce qu'il avait tort est-ce qu'il
avait raison est-ce qu'on le traite
comme ça c'est ça la question c'est quel
est quel est la durabilité des décisions
stratégiques en fait
en fait je crois que quand on s'engage
dans une crise celui qui en décide c'est
que c'est pas lui qui enverra l'issue
parce que les crises les crises ou la
résolution des crises ça se mesure pas
avec un chronomètre ça se mesure pas
avec
un truc à sable ça se mesure même pas
avec un calendrier ça se mesure avec des
décades et quand vous regardez un peu
l'état du monde quand vous regardez les
missions des Nations Unies vous savez
depuis combien de temps les Nations
Unies sont déployées à Chypre
40 ans depuis 1947 vous savez depuis
combien de temps la filleule est
déployée au Liban depuis 1978 etc etc et
donc c'est incompréhension de la durée
que prennent la résolution des crises
incompatible avec l'alternance politique
qui fait que l'engagement militaire de
la France dans une crise est avant tout
un sujet de politique intérieure c'est
avant tout un sujet de politique
intérieur alors si je comprenais c'est
du décorum politique
on est chef des armées on peut mettre le
sweat-shirt des comment c'était quel
switcher qui nous avait mis fort
spéciale de l'armée de l'air
il y avait même
simplement
le président Macron
et le seul président
qui a pas fait son service militaire non
ça c'est vrai aussi ça c'est vrai aussi
le président Macron et pas fait une
préparation militaire et le seul
président qui n'est pas engagé la France
dans la résolution militaire d'une crise
et oui lui il a hérité
il a engagé aucune résolution aucun
militaire dans une crise le président
Hollande l'a fait le président Sarkozy
l'a fait le président Chirac l'a fait
président
Mitterrand
Giscard tout cela l'ont fait et pas
Macron il a hérité des crises de ses
prédécesseurs mais le sujet est pas de
savoir si l'emporte ou pas une
responsabilité le sujet c'est que on ne
résout pas une crise en 5 ans on ne
résout pas une crise en 10 ans il faut
plus de temps la lucidité qu'est-ce
qu'il faut pour être lucide il faut des
bons yeux il faut des bonnes oreilles il
faut une bonne tête on est d'accord une
conduite introspective se remette en
question est-ce que vous trouvez qu'on
se remet en question qu'on a encore des
bons yeux et des bonnes oreilles pour
comprendre ce qui se passe
mais quand vous dites on sait à quel
niveau la France moi la France
il faut c'est je peux pas répondre à
cette question là moi je peux pas parler
pour la France ce que je peux vous dire
en matière de remise de remise en
question c'est ce qu'on fait dans les
armées ce qu'on essaie de faire ce qu'on
essaie de faire parce que je pense que à
thinkerview vous interviewez que des
elfes que des gens qui vivent dans un
monde parfait nous on n'est pas parfait
nous on n'est pas parfait
donc qu'est-ce qu'on essaie de faire
parce que parce que des services de
renseignement mais eux ont les
maltraitent un peu
mérité une OPEX un coup de bâton c'est
500 pompes alors qu'est-ce qu'on essaie
de faire pour essayer de sortir dans une
forme de conformisme qu'est-ce qu'on
essayait de faire maintenant moi j'ai
quitté depuis un certain temps dans les
exercices de planification ou dans les
exercices de crise
on crée ce qu'on appelle une rétine
on crée une RED team c'est très
compliqué une fois qu'on a dit ça c'est
très séduisant intellectuellement donc
on met une équipe qu'on sort un peu de
l'ambiance des Bleus les Bleus c'est des
gentils et les rouges chez nos ennemis
et les rouges ils sont entre ils
imaginent une stratégie comment on va
faire et ils essaient de se mettre dans
la peau de nos ennemis on avait fait ça
au moment de l'Afghanistan où j'avais
créé une redtime dont le chef était le
Molla Omar oui toi tu es le mot la
homard tu as 400 mecs c'est pas les plus
idiots et dis-moi quelle est ta
stratégie dis-moi ce que tu es prêt à
accepter comme comme mort pour obtenir
pour obtenir tes objectifs comment tu
vas faire partir les Américains etc etc
donc on fait ça ça c'est essayer de
penser différemment mais c'est très
difficile
on fait ça nous on n'a pas fait ça les
Américains ont fait ça après les
premiers tours d'Afghanistan ils avaient
des officiers pas tous ils avaient des
officiers qu'ils envoyaient en stage
accéléré pour apprendre le patchoul et
le dari ou et donc il y avait des
officiers qui parlaient qui parlaient la
langue ça aussi c'est des choses qu'on a
perdu
ces choses qu'on a perdu parce que parce
que la contrainte budgétaire parce que
les carrières ont fait que on passe
moins de temps à part les gens du Quai
d'Orsay qui ont lancé
si vous avez des gens qui parlent un
certain nombre de langues de langage
c'est assez rare chez nous on doit
former on doit former peut-être trois ou
quatre officiers qui parlent arabe
chaque année à peu près
bah l'arabe l'arabe
littéraire et qui ensuite passe par par
l'Égypte pour pour
perfectionner leur langue en tout cas
voilà donc
il y a bien il y a bien cette volonté
cette volonté d'essayer de voir les
choses avec un angle différent de voir
en oblique un certain nombre de crises
et d'essayer de se mettre à la place de
nos adversaires est-ce que vous pensez
que ça a été fait pour le confiance
je sais pas
je sais pas à la vue des marques des
coups de soleil on dirait que peut-être
non
[Musique]
quand
ça fait ça fait
une personne dépassée comme quand
j'étais allé l'idée quand j'étais à
l'Élysée on avait imaginé encore le
chauffage
je travaillais avec le conseiller
diplomatique chargé des Affaires
stratégiques à l'Élysée
et on est on avait on avait fait le
constat
que on avait fait le constat que les
administrations travaillent bien mais
dans une logique d'administration les
services les synthèses du Quai d'Orsay
les synthèse des armées etc etc et on
s'était dit c'est pas suffisant pour
éclairer les décisions du Président
c'est pas on pensait
et donc il faut trouver quelque chose
d'autre qui amène une vision qui est
radicalement différente qui est celle
des ONG on part entre là dedans mais
celle des grands industriels celle de
Total celle de Orange celle de
CMA CGM celle de ceux qui sont dans des
pays qui les connaissent avec un angle
très différent ou celle de spécialistes
des professeurs d'université des gens
dans des films tanks et donc on avait
proposé la création du CCOS le Conseil
consultatif d'orientation stratégique
qui n'était pas quelque chose de
permanent qui était quelque chose que le
président pouvait convoquer pour dire
donnez-moi votre analyse sur tel pays
tel conflit telle l'orientation telle
dérive ou telle perspective d'évolution
ce qui était pas mal non pas pour
court-circuiter les administrations mais
pour amener une autre vision
probablement la vision économique ou la
vision sociale ou la vision culturelle
ou la vision démographique et donc cette
idée avait remporté
tous les suffrages
Claude le président à gauche à droite
c'était une bonne idée etc puis ensuite
il a fallu mettre des noms
et dès qu'on met des noms c'est bien
compliqué parce que ça devient une
bataille d'ego et donc on a abandonné ce
projet je pense que c'est un bon projet
et je crois que le président Macron ou
l'équipe du président Macron a voulu
faire la même chose avec son CPA le
conseil pour l'Afrique qui est quelque
chose qui ne qui ne fait appel qu'à des
universitaires des industriels ou des
patrons d'entreprises africains que des
Africains et donc dans ma compréhension
il voulait faire ça il voulait avoir une
autre un autre avis une autre perception
des choses donnée par des Africains
eux-mêmes c'est ça qu'il faut faire
c'est ça qu'il faut réussir à faire en
préservant en préservant
le rôle des institutions telles que sont
définies par notre Constitution et puis
en préservant la sécurité des décisions
où la confidentialité d'un certain
nombre de décisions
on parle un peu de la Libye
ce grand succès
militaire et stratégique et diplomatique
pourquoi on a été on a été en Libye
c'était pour apporter la démocratie pour
les petites filles pour arrêter les
colonnes de Shark et les massacrer un
pays que les colonnes de chats ont les
fonds
pourquoi on est parti là-bas non mais
on est parti là-bas pour assurer que
l'espace aérien soit non non
un certain nombre de
pas duré si longtemps que ça finalement
militaire
de l'opération armateur elle s'appelait
harmathan a pas duré aussi longtemps que
ça c'est terminé
président voulait se terminer pour le 14
juillet de l'année je sais plus combien
2011 c'était en 2011 ça fait bien
l'annonce à 14 juillet c'est une belle
annonce
pourquoi on y est allé moi je peux vous
dire pourquoi ce qu'on m'a dit à moi
entre entre ce qui est la réalité moi ce
qu'on m'a dit à moi et ce que ce que
j'ai mis en œuvre c'était arrêter les
colonnes de char qui était à HDA Biya à
HDA c'est dans le Golf de cirque et qui
remontait vers Benghazi dans le sillage
des déclarations de Kadhafi qui était de
faire de faire couler des rivières de
sang à Benghazi
ensuite
sur cette opération
toujours ce CPCO fameux CPCO qui est
quand même le bon Génie le bon Génie des
décisions quand on avait déclenché cette
opération
dans des conditions un peu aussi après
acrobatiques je reviendrai là-dessus sur
la notion de crise
le CPCO comme d'habitude je vais dire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment vous voyez
les choses etc
il m'avait dit
mon général
si on y va trop fort si on y va trop
fort voilà les trois risques
potentiels le premier c'est qu'on va
créer des espaces lacunaires dans lequel
des djihadistes vont s'installer fait
le deuxième c'est que il va y avoir une
marée montante de tous les dépôts de
munitions de Libye vers le Sahel fait le
troisième c'est qu'on va casser le
barrage antimigrant que tient Kadhafi
fait donc là aussi on avait anticipé ça
on avait anticipé c'est pas non plus
vous avez prévenu on a prévenu on a
prévenu on m'a traité de menteur
traité de menteur on m'a dit c'est pas
vrai c'est faux
mais voilà donc des bons copains ils
sont très efficaces pardon on a des bons
copains ils sont très efficaces et donc
et donc voilà ça c'est
ça c'est passé comme ça ensuite
vous traite de menteur il est toujours
en poste je répondrai pas cette question
mais en tout cas voilà en tout cas on ne
voulait pas entendre ça on ne voulait
pas entendre que des djihadistes
allaient s'installer dans les espaces
qui auraient été plus occupés mal
occupés par par les forces les forces de
Kadhafi
et donc et donc
on a fait cette opération
qu'on devait faire initialement dans une
dans un commandement qui était
franco-britannique c'était ça l'idée
générale on s'était répartis les rôles
la partie dite commandement stratégique
devait avoir devait être déployé sur un
PC britannique
en Grande-Bretagne et puis nous à partir
de Lyon on devait traiter la partie
opérative et donc c'était l'accord
politique avait été passée entre le
président français et le Premier
ministre britannique et puis en fait
pour des raisons pour des raisons que
j'ignore je ne fais que supputer les
Britanniques se sont défilés et ils ont
foncé à Stuttgart pour se mettre sous
l'ombre des Américains et on a donné le
commandement aux Américains pour la
première phase de l'opération en Libye
donc c'est une opération qui était
commandée par les Américains
le président américain a fait ça pendant
une semaine ou 10 jours il est dit ok je
fais ça pendant 10 jours et ensuite je
m'en vais et ensuite ça a été l'OTAN qui
a pris le commandement de cette
opération
[Musique]
et donc et donc c'est donc moi j'ai
appris une chose à travers cette
opération
je pensais que l'OTAN c'était quelque
chose c'était un cerveau et en fait mais
il faut apprendre à tout âge et en fait
l'OTAN c'est des processus c'est une
administration et c'est des processus
mais elle est pas habité et donc quand
il y a une opération de l'OTAN il faut
qu'il y ait un leader il faut qu'il y
ait un leader qui donne la direction qui
donne le rythme etc et moi j'avais pas
compris ça je croyais que quand c'était
l'OTAN c'était l'OTAN donc on faisait
plus rien non mais l'OTAN il fait rien
il déroule des processus il y a des
accords de coordination ou de
standardisation entre les différentes
composantes mais c'est pas lui qui met
du souffle il souffle pas dans les
tuyaux il dit voilà les tuyaux et donc
et donc il se passait pas grand chose
les avions des collègues ils tournaient
ils atterrissaient ils des collègues etc
jusqu'au moment où j'ai compris que
c'était à nous de prendre le leadership
militaire Militaire parce qu'on était
les plus engagés les plus nombreux en
matière de d'Asset aérien etc et donc on
a fait
j'étais chef de CPC à l'époque et donc
on a fait sur un pas sur un bout de
table un plan une planification
stratégique avec le sous-chefox de
l'époque qui était l'amiral regel qu'on
a présenté à notre ministre et qui l'a
présenté à l'occasion d'une réunion des
ministres de la défense de la coalition
c'est ça qu'on a mis en œuvre donc moi
j'ai appris ce que c'était qu'une
coalition de l'OTAN et donc quand il y a
les Américains personne se pose la
question c'est les Américains qui
commandent quand ils sont pas là il faut
quelqu'un dise je vais le faire donc
voilà donc c'est comme ça que ça s'est
mis en place
et contrairement à ce qui a été raconté
contrairement à certaines versions où on
accuse où on
accuse ou on soupçonne le président
Sarkozy d'avoir donné des ordres pour
éliminer Kadhafi c'est tout le contraire
moi j'avais des ordres écrits pour me
dire quels étaient les objectifs qu'on
ne devait pas viser et on n'avait pas le
droit de s'en prendre mais pas le droit
il était interdit non target list ça
s'appelle de s'en prendre à Kadhafi
interdit de s'en prendre à son directeur
de cabinet Béchère salé interdit de s'en
prendre à son chef des renseignements et
interdit de s'en prendre à camis qui
était son fils donc on avait donc c'est
le président il a pas dit tuer les il a
dit non je ne veux pas qu'il se passe
des choses comme ça et quand ça s'est
passé
parce que l'histoire est je sais pas si
elle a été raconté je sais pas
d'ailleurs si elle présente beaucoup
d'intérêts donc il y avait des avions
les avions d'école ils se mettaient en
CAP ils se mettent à tourner en rond
hippodrome en hippodrome alors en
hippodrome c'est ça il se mette en
hippodrome et puis les gens qui sont au
sol voient des objectifs ou n'en voit
pas et désigne aux avions qui vont
repères identifient en compte auquel
l'autorisation étire
et donc c'était des Néerlandais des F-16
néerlandais qui était là qui était en
hippodrome et à ce moment-là on voit
surgir de la ville de cirque une longue
colonne de gros pick-up noir
impressionnant qui était qui était
probablement des classiques du régime
qui fuyaient qui fuit
et le général Bouchard merveilleux
officier canadien qui commandait
l'opération un pilote d'hélicoptère
donne l'ordre au néerlandais non pas de
détruire la colonne mais d'arrêter la
colonne c'est-à-dire taper le premier
véhicule et taper le dernier véhicule ce
qui pour les ce qui pour les gens de
l'armée de l'air est un truc ils font ça
comme ils font une omelette c'est un
truc très facile pour eux ils donnent
l'ordre néerlandais et les Néerlandais
leur disent non nous on est on est en
fin de Kero fin de potentiel on doit
rentrer et donc les Néerlandais ça
arrive et à s'en vont et ceux qui les
remplacent sur l'hippodrome c'est des
mirages de 1000 français et c'est eux
qui arrivent là et qui reçoivent l'ordre
qui prennent en compte la mission à 10
minutes près ça aurait été les
Néerlandais 10 minutes après c'était les
Français donc ceux qui voient là dedans
une manœuvre orchestrée par l'Elysée de
mettre les avions français pour faire ça
à mon avis
rentre dans la longue corde des
complotistes et donc ça s'est passé
comme ça c'est très intéressant ce que
vous dites sur Béchir salé
oui et Moussa Koussa aussi et Moussa
Koussa Bechir salé
je sais plus comment s'appelait le chef
des services de renseignement qui a été
qui a été mis en prison pendant un long
temps en Libye qui vient d'être qui
vient d'être libéré je crois mais voilà
donc ensuite qu'est-ce qu'il y a
derrière mais la vraie histoire la vraie
histoire ou l'enchaînement des faits
c'est ça les Français ils seraient
arrivés 10 minutes après l'affaire était
faite et la mission c'était pas détruire
la colonne c'était l'interrompre et puis
ensuite il y a eu ce qui est arrivé
changeons de sujet comment vous percevez
la situation actuelle la France va
devenir quoi est-ce que vous avez vous
êtes top vous êtes plutôt optimiste
plutôt réaliste plutôt lucide comment
comment vous percevez le changement de
braquet géopolitique que l'Europe est en
train de subir
il y a deux choses il y a l'Europe
puissance va-t-elle devenir une
puissance et il y a la France dans
l'Europe il y a une expression il y a
une expression que je trouve délicieuse
j'aurais bien voulu en être à l'origine
et là je la dois je crois à un pont de
l'Union européenne c'est les Européens
dans les relations internationales et
dans et dans la géopolitique actuelle
c'est un trop beau c'est un troupeau
d'herbivores dans un épisode de Jurassic
Park et je trouve que l'expression est
assez bonne on est un troupeau
derbivores dans un épisode de Jurassic
Park et je pense que on va voir ce qui
va changer avec les décisions du
chancelier allemand les 100 milliards la
première armée conventionnelle d'Europe
mais on verra on verra on verra on verra
on verra déjà on va attendre qu'il finit
son terminal gazier pour l'année
prochaine qui récupère ses 8% de
capacités de gaz puis après on verra les
100 milliards et puis on verra tout ça
on verra je suis d'accord on verra pour
l'instant pour l'instant
moi ce que j'ai observé donc je parle
pas de ce qui va se passer ce que j'ai
observé c'est que dans le domaine de la
défense
l'Union européenne ne veut pas être une
puissance elle ne veut pas être une
puissance militaire dans le domaine de
la défense ça c'est la première chose et
et il ne suffit de constater les pseudos
opérations européennes qui ont été
conduites
dès que c'est des opérations au sol il y
a la plus grande il y a la plus grande
fragilité et la plus grande méfiance des
Européens pour ça ils ne veulent pas de
ça ils ne veulent pas de ça parce que je
pense que les Européens en général les
Allemands en particulier
sont quand même encore extrêmement
marqués par la deuxième guerre mondiale
par non pas par le nazisme par les
pertes par les morts et donc il y a une
vraie
il y a une vraie une vraie peur de se
relancer dans des dans les choses
offensives ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose comme tout le monde il y
a eu les dividendes de la paix comme
tout le monde Laurent Fabius qui a été
le premier à le dire
c'était toucher les dividendes de la
paix en pensant que ce qu'on
économiserait sur la défense et qu'on
investirait dans le domaine social
consoliderait nos armées s'avère que je
sais pas s'il fallait continuer à
investir beaucoup dans les armées en
tout cas ça a pas consolidé nos sociétés
vous savez il y a un chiffre il y a un
chiffre qui est très important très
important qu'il est intéressant de
partager avec votre communauté c'est que
en 1960 le PIB c'était de combien dans
la défense
du PIB qui était consacré à la défense
c'était 5%
5% du PIB consacré à la défense en 1960
et en
1980 ou 82 ça devait être 3,4 et en 19
[Musique]
14 ou 15 c'était 1,7 voilà et donc les
transferts ils ont lieu dans le domaine
social parce que moi ce que je conteste
pas si jamais ça avait un effet le
deuxième volet de chiffres que je
voudrais que vous ayez en tête
la marine chinoise
c'est 1% de la population mondiale c'est
3% de la richesse mondiale et c'est 13%
des transferts sociaux
1 3 13 et donc très clairement si on a
une stratégie c'est celle-là c'est celle
du ventre bien remplie pour peu que ça
le remplisse 1 3 13 et en dépit ça on a
une société dont il semble quand même
que la cohésion est plutôt fragile
est-ce que vous croyez la dislocation
géopolitique mondiale
est-ce que le
est-ce que vous croyez que les Russes
c'est terminé
ils vont se tourner vers les Chinois et
les Indiens
alors ils vont laisser crever l'Europe
les Américains les Russes les Chinois
vont se partager les les restes de
l'Europe
mais vous me demandez
vous me demandez ce que j'en pense parce
que j'ai pas de compétences
particulières moi ce que je regarde vous
vous sentez moi ce que je sens je suis
pas capable de sentir dans le domaine
économique je pense que dans le domaine
de la puissance
la Chine est en train de connaître une
décrue démographique qui est quand même
extrêmement importante et c'est la même
problématique de natalité en Russie donc
pour moi ces deux pays ces deux pays à
des échéances différentes sont des
étoiles qui brillent encore mais elles
sont mortes
c'est des étoiles qui brillent encore
mais elles sont mortes pour des raisons
démographiques mais non tout ça peut
changer en tout cas regardez les taux de
natalité
chinois et russes c'est des pays qui
sont en train non pas de disparaître
mais qui sont en train de s'affaiblir et
je pense que la dimension économique est
extrêmement importante sur l'évolution
géopolitique mais les questions
démographiques le sont aussi vous savez
vous savez
combien pèse combien pèsera l'Afrique en
2050 dans la population du monde ça
dépend avant ou après réchauffement
climatique
sur la base des prospectivistes qui
parlent de ça un habitant de la planète
sur quatre sera africain un habitant de
la planète sur 4 sera africain et 60%
aura moins de 18 ans ce qui sera
africain en Afrique où il sera africains
mais non mais ça c'est une autre
question mais en tout cas je pense que
on néglige on néglige pas qu'on néglige
je comprends la question économique mais
je pense que la question démographique
est une question qui est extrêmement
importante pour l'avenir des relations
internationales
sur est-ce que la France va devenir
c'était quoi votre expression est-ce que
la France va se tire mon disait non
c'était pas ça non
une petite moyenne je sais pas quoi
puissance c'est une puissance de moyenne
impuissance
je pense qu'il y a un sujet plus
particulier de moyen un sujet
européen on l'a pas évoqué enfin on a
tiré quelques grandes lignes
il y a la problématique de la relation
de la France à l'Afrique
ça c'est ça c'est un sujet ça c'est un
sujet qui à mon avis est important quand
on voit les campagnes de dénigrement
anti-française qui sont parfois
orchestrés par des acteurs étrangers
parfois mais qui sont aussi parfois
parfois spontanés il y a pas il y a pas
que que préjuguing qui s'occupe de ça
et là je pense que on n'a pas encore
réussi à sortir du fardeau de l'homme
blanc fardeau de l'homme blanc du
sanglot de l'homme blanc comme dit
Bruckner c'est à dire notre complexe ou
notre culpabilité de de coloniser je
pense qu'on regarde pas l'Afrique avec
les bons yeux on garde pas l'Afrique
avec les bons yeux donc vous êtes partis
faire un petit tour de bus et taxi Bruce
tout seul comment vous savez ça
on a le grand bras on a le grand bras on
a les grandes oreilles et on a le regard
vif comme vous pouvez le remarquer
alerte alerte
non j'ai fait ça
j'ai fait ça
en fait pour vos pour votre communauté
quand j'ai fini ma carrière militaire je
suis parti
habillé comme Job pauvre comme Job avec
un tout petit sac à dos je me suis fait
déposer à Tanger et je suis allé par les
moyens du bord les moyens africains
camions de transport public
taxibrose à pied une fois avec un âne
jusque
soit
jusqu'à Sierra Leone et ensuite je suis
rentré au Mali pourquoi j'ai fait ça
parce que vous êtes chaud quand même
j'ai pas réussi à rentrer c'est trop
compliqué je vous raconterai l'anecdote
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai fait ça comment
rentrer à la frontière à pied pourquoi
pourquoi j'ai fait ça
d'abord parce que je voulais faire un
peu comme nos enfants comme les enfants
qui nous écoutent je voulais faire une
espèce de césure à la fin de ma carrière
militaire pour dire ça c'est fini c'est
passé voilà même si tu penses que tu as
été indispensable à l'horlogerie du
monde c'est passé donc je voulais faire
une césure donc je suis parti pendant
deux mois ou deux mois et demi et
ensuite parce que je me suis dit que
je pensais connaître l'Afrique je
pensais aimer l'Afrique et en fait je la
connaissais
ou comme un touriste rarement mais comme
un militaire et donc je voulais voir une
partie
et donc je voulais voir l'Afrique je
voulais voir l'Afrique à hauteur
d'Afrique et donc je voulais
vivre comme eux manger comme eux
me déplacer comme eux
et donc j'ai fait ça je vous recommande
un hôtel à Nouakchott à 1,50 € la nuit
on dort pas beaucoup un euro
pèlerinage en Afrique vous avez prévenu
les services de renseignement vous allez
vous balader là-bas ou parce que moi
personnellement je suis dans les
services je vois le général ancien du
CPCO partir et que c'est tongs et cette
DJ là-bas je l'écoute mon grand tu es
gentil mais il va falloir qu'on aille te
chercher si tu te faire payer quand même
ça c'est passé comme ça ça s'est fait
comme ça avec les tongs non avec non ça
s'est passé comme ça et mon successeur
m'a dit il est pas question que tu
partes comme ça donc il m'a pris par la
main il m'a amené chez Au Vieux Campeur
il m'a fait acheter une balise il m'a
dit voilà tu as pu ras là-dessus etc et
puis je vais donner mon itinéraire et on
a fait en sorte que tout ça soit connu
et Sue des des services et des gens qui
étaient capables de me récupérer
et donc j'ai fait ça et donc j'ai fait
ça et donc j'ai appris j'ai appris
deux ou trois choses
d'abord j'ai appris le temps
les
occidentaux on est obsédé par le temps
ça veut rien dire le son
non mais c'était ça c'était délicieux et
donc les la première semaine j'étais
obsédé est-ce que je vais avoir mon
moyen de transport est-ce que je vais
arriver à tel endroit oui non j'avais
peur de pas y arriver puis en fait il y
a un moment on déjauge comme un bateau
tout ça n'a plus d'intérêt on arrive on
arrive pas toute façon il y a toujours
il y a toujours une solution donc j'ai
appris le temps le plus important c'est
quand même le rouleau de PQ et l'Imodium
non elle s'en fout on s'en fout du temps
la deuxième chose j'ai appris j'ai pas
appris mais j'ai j'ai compris
la problématique de l'hospitalité il
m'est arrivé d'avoir deux ou trois
tracas d'arrivée en pleine nuit pas à
l'endroit où je devais arriver il
pleuvait etc dans des petits villages en
brousse en Guinée notamment en Guinée
Conakry et ben là-bas quand il y a blanc
qui est tout seul au milieu de la route
trempée avec l'air agars il y a
quelqu'un qui vous dit viens chez moi
qui donne un coup de pied à ses deux
enfants qui sont sur une natte qui vous
dit tu peux dormir là qui vous nourrit
le soir et le matin et qui vous demande
rien il vous demande pas d'argent il
fait merci au revoir qu'est-ce que tu es
venu faire ici très bien au revoir donc
j'ai appris l'hospitalité et je
comprends un peu mieux parfois
l'espèce de stupéfaction des étrangers
en France quand ils voient l'absence
d'hospitalité de notre côté voilà et
puis la troisième la troisième chose
j'ai appris
j'ai appris la bonne humeur et le rire
c'est à dire que là-bas toute chose qui
n'est pas la mort la blessure la maladie
fait rire celui qui casse la figure avec
son plateau sur la tête celui qui tombe
de vélo etc ça donne lieu à des espèces
de flambées de discussion etc et à la
fin tout le monde rigole et à la fin
tout le monde rigole et donc ça a été ça
a été un très bon moment et dans tous
les pays où je suis passé il y avait
quand même aussi une version pédagogique
je m'arrêtais dans les capitales dans
les souks au livre scolaire dans les
souks au livre scolaire et dans tous les
pays Maroc Mauritanie Sénégal
Guinée Sierra Leone non et Mali j'ai
acheté le livre de 4e le livre
d'histoire de quatrième le livre
d'histoire de 4e pour voir comment
l'histoire est racontée aux enfants et
quand vous lisez ces livres quand vous
lisez ce qu'on met dans la tête des
enfants comme ce qu'on met dans la tête
de nos enfants mais vous comprenez quand
même qu'on n'est pas toujours bien
accueilli et vous comprenez que si les
gens vous sourient derrière il y a un
fond qui est pas celui-là qui est pas
celui-là et ça c'est aussi une chose je
me rends compte trop tard mais pour
pouvoir parler avec ces gens-là il faut
comprendre comment ils ont été élevés
qu'est-ce qu'on leur a appris de leur
propre histoire et dans tous ces pays là
palmaroc mais dans tous ces pays là
l'histoire de la colonisation c'est pas
une histoire positive on peut pas croire
que ces gens-là nous accueillent
maintenant
60 maintenant il avait 10 ans 12 ans
mais ces gens-là nous accueillent pas à
bras ouverts
en tout cas ça a été ça a été une très
bonne expérience et ça m'a permis de
franchir le pas
quelques questions à Internet
on en est où avec nos munitions en cas
de conflit de haute intensité c'est
3 jours 4 jours 5 jours on a le temps de
passer le week-end
est-ce qu'on va être obligé d'appeler
nos chasseurs pour tirer un coup de 12
[Rires]
[Musique]
oui nos stocks de munitions sont
déraisonnablement bas et c'est pas nous
et c'est pas nouveau quand on quand on
était engagé en Syrie en Irak on tirait
des bombes qui s'appelle les adossesm
c'est des bombes qui ont un kit de
guidage qu'on peut tirer à 40 km de
l'objectif qui vont sur l'objectif c'est
des bombes qui valent je crois
deux écoles pardon deux écoles non je
sais pas je crois que c'était trois
écoles je crois que c'est 100000 euros 5
écoles c'est 100000 euros la bombe et
donc évidemment
on faisait la guerre contre contre daesh
vous allez battait contre daesh et donc
à un moment on me dit mon général il
faut arrêter il dit pourquoi parce qu'on
en a plus
parce qu'on a plus beaucoup on a plus
beaucoup et donc et donc pendant une
grande partie de notre engagement Syrie
en Irak c'est bon là ils étaient
rationnés donc j'autorisais de tirer
petit tirer d'autres bombes aussi
j'autorisais de tirer tant de bombe par
semaine tant de par semaine d'ailleurs
et pas plus ça c'était pour les bombes
la partie la plus la plus stratégique là
dedans c'est les kits de guidage c'est
toujours l'équipe de gage le reste c'est
un corps un corps avec des ailettes et
le kit de guidage il était fait par
haïton une société
et donc copain nos copains et donc il
fallait ils appelaient mais eux ils
disaient mais nous aussi on en a besoin
etc donc il y a des dépendances il y a
des dépendances qui sont le nombre de
bons ou de cordes il y a des dépendances
pour des des parties des bombes donc
pour en revenir à la question combien de
temps nos stocks me permettrait de tenir
je comprends le sens de la question j'ai
vu des généraux qui se prononçaient
là-dessus trois jours pour notre nous
avions tant de jours etc je pense que
effectivement nos stocks comme je le
disais sont des raisonnements bas
mais je pense aussi qu'il faut mettre en
place des scénarios c'est à dire qu'on
se retrouvera jamais dans la situation
de l'Ukraine ou alors ça veut dire que
l'Union européenne l'OTAN tout ça n'a
pas de sens donc on sera pas attaqué sur
notre territoire avant que ne soit
attaqué tous les pays qui sont plus à
l'est ou ailleurs ou qu'on décide d'un
engagement majeur à l'extérieur du
territoire national contre contre une
puissance régionale donc
c'est insuffisant c'est un constat qui
est fait à la fois par les militaires
qui est fait à la fois par les
politiques ce sera probablement qui a
été fait par un député qui s'appelle
monsieur thiero qui a fait un rapport
parlementaire là-dessus ça sera une des
priorités de la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire maintenant dire
trois jours quatre jours tout ça dépend
de scénario et de la façon dont on va se
battre ce que j'espère
ce que j'espère c'est que si on est dans
une situation comme l'Ukraine
effectivement tous les chasseurs
viendrai avec leur 12 pour défendre
notre pays normal
l'intelligence artificielle la prise de
décision l'étale la prise de décision
l'étale imaginez-vous vous avez une
frontière
et puis hop il voit un migrant ou un
assaillant ou Ikea alors c'est c'est un
sujet qui c'est pas c'est un sujet qui
est important le la dénomination de ces
systèmes d'armes s'appelle nous on
appelle ça les Salah sa elle a les
systèmes autonomes
je sais pas quoi c'est ça c'est donc les
trucs qui sont capables en intelligence
artificielle de pouvoir
identifier un objectif le reconnaître et
le traiter
on a créé un groupe éthique et
déontologie c'est Madame Parly qui avait
créé ça le traité c'est le vocabulaire
Salah Salah c'est le nom d'objectif
traiter un objectif ouais c'est le
vocabulaire militaire ça traite un
objectif ça veut dire le détruire oui
et donc quand il y a eu ce sujet des
salaks a été porté par des ONG en disant
c'est inadmissible etc madame Parly a
créé un groupe éthique sur la question
des Salah qui je crois était présidé par
un ancien c-ma que vous avez reçu ici
qui est généralement déjà qui présidait
ce groupe et dans lequel se poser la
question de savoir qu'est-ce qui était
Sala qu'est-ce qu'il était pas est-ce
qu'on interdisait nous aussi est-ce
qu'on ralliait une association d'ONG qui
voulait bannir les Sala el Sala et en
gros les décisions qui ont été les
décisions qui ont été prises ce qui a
été dit à l'issue de cette réflexion
c'est en France en tout cas jusqu'à
maintenant aucune arme ne pourrait
décider seul d'engager
la force ou de détruire un objectif
aucune arme ne pourrait seul décider
d'engager une cible il y aura toujours
un homme dans le dans le dispositif
comme pour les drones comme pour notre
drone il y a toujours un homme toujours
un homme qui décide ou non de tirer sur
l'intelligence artificielle ça c'est un
vrai sujet sur lequel on doit réfléchir
parce que maintenant il y a une telle
masse de données à analyser que le
cerveau humain peut pas le faire ou
qu'on n'a pas assez d'hommes pour
analyser tout ça donc il faut savoir
comment on est capable d'industrialiser
la synthèse de ces données et il faut
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on met comme algo
derrière comme algorithme il faut savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on met comme algorithme
derrière et quelle est quelle est la
marge qu'on laisse au chef militaire
parce que parce que c'est ce que disait
je crois clausvitz la guerre est un
caméléon chaque guerre est différente et
on peut pas croire qu'on va rentrer ça
dans un logiciel il y a un moment où
l'intelligence humaine ou l'intuition
humaine ou la prise de risque la prise
de risque elle va à l'encontre de
l'intelligence artificielle ou la prise
de risque fait la différence et donc il
faudra toujours quel que soit le niveau
d'intelligence artificielle qu'on laisse
cette capacité au chef militaire de
décider
moi ce que j'ai ce que j'ai vu quand
même
à travers les différentes opérations
c'est pas la guerre c'est que
avec des processus
qui permettent de ne pas prendre de
risques on peut on peut ne pas perdre
quand on ne prend pas de risque on peut
ne pas perdre on peut jamais gagner
dans le champ militaire c'est
automatiquement lié à la prise de risque
de l'administration
pas de couilles pas d'embrouille
je connais absolument pas cette adage
je crois vraiment que
la guerre la guerre complètement
technique c'est à dire quand on a un
problème on met une on met des bombes
quand le problème n'est pas résolu on
met plus de bon et encore plus de bombe
et encore plus de bons et on privilégie
le zéro mort on peut pas gagner on peut
ne pas perdre d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
depuis qu'on fait ça on ne perd aucune
guerre mais on peut pas gagner pour
gagner il faut prendre des risques ça
qui est ça qui est difficile
le fait que c'est Nicolas Sarkozy qui
nous a fait réintégrer le conseil de
l'OTAN non
le conseil de l'OTAN l'expression
délicieuse c'était la France reprend sa
place pleine et entière dans l'OTAN
c'est un très bon sujet c'est un très
bon sujet parce que ça a été un sujet de
la campagne électorale où tout le monde
a dit qu'on s'était un féodé aux
Américains dans le cadre de l'OTAN etc
mais c'est complètement faux mais c'est
complètement faux d'abord parce que
l'OTAN fonctionne sur
[Musique]
les décisions de l'OTAN fonctionnent sur
le mode de l'unanimité de l'unanimité
donc il n'y a pas de il y a pas de
majorité relative si la France toute
seule dans l'OTAN dit non elle le fera
pas ça c'est la première chose donc il y
a pas de souci sur le temps elle va se
faire taper sur les doigts sur d'autres
trucs
mais parce que vous croyez que dans la
vie c'est pas comme ça dans la vie il y
a chacun des intérêts et quand vous
défendez violemment un de vos intérêts
probablement vous allez devoir négocier
et abandonner un autre sauf si vous êtes
le plus gros et le plus fort sauf si
vous avez le plus gros marteau
ça s'appelle l'ordre mélien
de Délos c'est j'ai pour pour pas pour
finir là-dessus d'abord parce que j'ai
écouté avec délectation louis-finaz
raconter
raconter la ligue de Délos et puis parce
que j'ai étudié ça quand je préparais
Saint-Cyr le cinquième siècle de avant
Jésus-Christ le siècle de Périclès c'est
évidemment la Ligue d'Hélios que Loïc
final a habilement assimilé à l'OTAN
habilement assimilé à l'OTAN mais tout
ça pour dire que
ça ne change absolument rien sur notre
dévolution ou notre surbordination à
l'OTAN et le grand sujet à l'époque où
le président Sarkozy a pris cette
décision c'était ce qu'on appelle le NPG
le NPG dans l'OTAN vous savez que l'OTAN
est une force nucléaire
le NPG c'est le nucléaire planning group
soi-disant on y planifie avec les gens
de l'OTAN en fait il y a rien ça se
partage pas et donc la question c'était
est-ce que la France va mettre sa
dissuasion dans le NPG en fait la France
est pas dans le NPG donc ça change
absolument rien si ce n'est que on est
un peu plus intégré dans l'OTAN avec un
certain nombre de postes de
responsabilités et probablement l'idée
générale c'était de faire tomber tant
qu'on était pas revenu dans le temps la
méfiance qui avait les Européens sur
notre
politique vis-à-vis de l'Europe de la
défense donc tout le monde croyait que
on poussait l'Europe de la défense comme
alternative à l'OTAN et donc le
président Sarkozy et les diplomates ont
dit revenons complètement dans l'OTAN
comme ça il y aura plus cet argument et
ce qu'on veut faire en Europe ne sera
pas lié ne sera pas lié ou ne sera pas
décrit comme une opposition à l'OTAN
est-ce que vous avez des sujets que vous
voulez aborder avec nous
ça dépend combien de temps il reste
qu'on veut
il y a mon fils qui attend dehors pour
venir vous saluer
ça fait combien de temps qu'on parle ça
fait pas longtemps ça fait deux heures
on voit pas le temps passer ici non
c'est vrai c'est vrai est-ce qu'il y a
des choses
dont je vais vous parler
j'aurais bien voulu vous parler du
processus décisionnel mais d'abord je
dirais enfin je veux bien je serais ravi
de répondre aux questions de la
communauté si elle a des questions venez
de répondre à deux trois questions sans
vous en rendre compte
la question de Mathis que pense-t-il de
l'entrée de 2007 dans l'OTAN vous avez
déjà répondu
on vous laisse réfléchir 2 secondes pour
le sujet non non moi je voudrais si moi
je veux aborder un truc l'arithmétique
de la souffrance là
rythmétique de la rébellion pardon c'est
grâce à Elise 05 on avait gagné ce temps
combien de cils tués par les drones ça
m'a fait penser à ça donc l'arithmétique
de la rébellion alors attends
les américains ils arrivent avec leur
gros marteau leur gros problème qui
ressemble que à des clous il tape sur
tout le monde il TAPIS Tapis capitale
vas-y
uranieux ma pauvry en flat total on
bombarde tout leur stratégie qui est
complètement différente de celle des
Russes c'est-à-dire que les Russes ils
ne font pas le tapis bon d'abord donc
ils font le tapis d'obus
par jour je sais pas 2000 3000 ans
60000 obus par jour donc en matière de
tapis de bombe ça coûte moins cher que
de faire voler un avion c'est ça oui oui
sûrement mais 60000 quand même au but de
252 mm ou 122 mm quand même ça fait de
la ferraille ça va faire propre pour
la bourrer les champs
on a une expérience à Verdun on pourra
l'envoyer nos démineurs
et revenons revenons à nos moutons
l'arithmétique de la rébellion c'est ça
ça consiste à quoi c'est
en fait
c'est la façon dont je l'écris dont je
décris l'adversaire asymétrique
parce qu'on parce que pendant moi depuis
que je m'occupe des opérations et en
2002 j'étais en Côte d'Ivoire avec le
régiment que je commandais sur la
cavalie la cavalie c'est le fleuve
frontière entre le Liberia et la Côte
d'Ivoire et depuis ce temps-là je
regarde enfin je regarde non pas comme
un spectateur désengagé mais comme un
spectateur engagé je regarde comment ont
évolué les modes d'action de l'ennemi ce
que c'est que l'ennemi et notamment
l'ennemi asymétrique et quand je décris
l'ennemi asymétrique je le décris pas
pour pour faire un tableau de Fragonard
je le décris pour essayer de comprendre
ce qu'on doit faire ou pas faire
et donc la première des la première des
choses
c'est que cette ennemi quand on est à
l'extérieur du territoire national c'est
un ennemi qui nous lance volance et
protégée contre sa volonté ou pas par la
population il vit dans la population ça
c'est la première chose et donc quand on
recourt à la force pour essayer de
l'éliminer le tuer il paraît que les
militaires ont peur de dire tuer tout le
monde nous dit nous on dit neutraliser
le vocabulaire traiter traiter un
objectif très un objectif je traite les
cafards
et donc il paraît quand on dit
neutraliser tout le monde y a les
militaires veulent pas dire tuer ici on
dit tuer mais on veut pas toujours tuer
parfois on veut faire prisonnier en tout
cas quand cet ennemi est protégé par la
population on doit être extrêmement
discriminant dans la façon dont tu
utilises la force pourquoi
au titre de la règle de l'arithmétique
de la rébellion
l'arithmétique de la rébellion c'est
quand vous tuez un innocent ou quelqu'un
qui n'est pas un ennemi vous faites
lever vous faites lever contre vous son
frère son père son cousin ses fils c'est
à dire pour un tuer vous en faites 4 de
plus et donc c'est ça la rythmétique de
la rébellion c'est ça nous oblige à une
très très grande discrimination dans
l'emploi de la force et il est
maintenant quasiment patent même si on
le dit pas comme ça que au Sahel les
gens qui sont opposés à Bamako sont plus
nombreux maintenant qu'il l'était en
2013 donc c'est ça l'arithmétique de la
rébellion et donc nous on a l'obligation
de prendre en compte
[Musique]
cette cette règle entre guillemets non
seulement pour des raisons des raisons
éthiques on tue pas des innocents on est
quand même très respectueux
des protocoles de jeunesse du droit
international humanitaire
proportionnalité humanité distinction
etc mais aussi parce que ça nous fait
émerger plus d'ennemis qu'on en avait au
départ
le droit le devoir de guerre le droit de
la guerre ok
certes on doit pas être plus bourreau
que les bourreaux mais mais c'est loin
international de guerre
ça marche quand c'est un état en face
non non
est-ce que vous comprenez le but de ma
question je comprends et je vais vous
répondre par une citation latine
in forum de Lorraine
UBS rénovaré Regina vous savez ce que
c'est
c'est le c'est la réponse que fait
que fait aimer à la reine-didon qui lui
demande de lui raconter la guerre de
Troie il lui dit vous rouvrez une
blessure lancinante à peu près et quand
vous me posez cette question vous me
vous rouvrez une blessure lancinante
parce que j'ai été confronté à ça j'ai
été confronté à ça moi je crois
j'ai des confronté à ça en Syrie et en
Irak en Syrie après je pense que c'était
je sais pas si c'était pas après Charlie
je pense que c'était
après
Bataclan
et donc et donc très clairement
l'émotion l'émotion avec dépassé le
stade de l'émotion
l'exécutif était dans une frénésie et
évidemment il y avait de quoi et donc il
y a un conseil de défense
et à l'occasion ce conseil de défense
quelqu'un entre guillemets donne les
coordonnées d'un immeuble à RACA en
disant ils sont tous dedans
tous les Forin facteurs français qui
sont à l'origine de cette attentat ils
sont dedans il faut tirer dessus
ils sont tous dedans il faut tirer sur
cette sur cette immeuble
et donc moi j'étais
sous chef et donc je reçois je reçois
cet ordre il faut tirer sur cette
immeuble voilà les coordonnées je lui
dis mais on fait pas ça mais comment ça
le président assume et j'ai dit mais le
président assume rien c'est pas lui qui
assume c'est moi qui vais donner l'ordre
et c'est un pilote qui va tirer dessus
et je lui dis je ne fais pas ça dans cet
immeuble d'abord on d'abord je pense
qu'on n'a pas de source sur place et
donc dans cet immeuble est-ce qu'il y a
pas une crèche est-ce qu'il y a pas une
maternité est-ce qu'il y a pas une
mosquée c'est et donc j'ai refusé j'ai
dit non je ferai pas ça je ferais pas ça
dans ces conditions là et je l'ai pas
fait et je l'ai pas fait simplement ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que
d'abord
profondément je crois que la France la
France notre pays ne pratique pas la loi
du talion et ne pratique pas la
politique de la vengeance voilà on fait
pas ça on se bat c'est plus c'est plus
la chevalerie d'antan mais en tout cas
on fait pas ça
on fait pas ça parce que parce que tout
le monde est en train de perdre les
pédales dans dans la pire des atrocités
ceci amène ceci amène à une autre
considération
avant la torture
ceci amène à une autre considération
c'est que les militaires d'abord il faut
qu'on soit conscient il faut qu'on soit
conscient des effets de la force et
comme vous le soulignez plus personne
parmi les politiques ne connaissaient
le président n'a pas fait son service
militaire les ministres les députés etc
personne ne connaît l'effet de la force
on dit on dit qu'aujourd'hui une
compagnie d'infanterie 150 personnes ils
ont la puissance de feu d'un bataillon
de 14-18
la puissance de feu d'un bataillon de
14-18 ensuite je pense que parmi parmi
je dis pas qu'il faut passer par là mais
je pense que qui n'a pas vu une herbeurs
tapée sur sur un sur un groupement
d'individus une airburst c'est une bombe
qui explose qu'on règle et qui explose à
10 mètres du sol
bombe d'avion quiconque n'a pas vu
l'effet du nerbos de doit quand même se
méfier de ses décisions et donc faut
dire ce que ça fait ça fait des petits
morceaux au sol
on peut faire
tacos angeladas tout de suite bon
toujours est-il que voilà et je pense
que évidemment c'est pas c'est si on a
vu le président Hollande complètement
défait au moment de Bataclan c'est parce
qu'il a vu ce que c'était que les effets
des armes quand il est allé sur le
trottoir qu'il a vu tous les gens
aligner qu'il a vu ce que ça fait c'est
ça qui est terrible et donc et donc je
pense qu'il y a un rôle particulier des
militaires
ça roule particulier c'est quand
l'hystérie ou quand l'émotion est trop
vive le militaire il doit mettre de la
distance et il doit mettre de la
rationalité dans les décisions de la
rationalité française militaire français
question et puis à l'inverse à l'inverse
quand la techno structure est en train
de prendre le pas dans la dans la
conduite des opérations etc le militaire
il est là pour mettre de l'humanité dans
ce que c'est qu'une opération de
l'humanité il faut c'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure ou avant qu'on
commence sur il faut aller sur le
terrain il faut aller dormir il faut
aller avoir peur il faut avoir froid il
faut avoir faim il faut avoir soif
de la torture
c'est efficace et pas efficace ça sert à
quelque chose ça sert à rien en fait ça
sert à rien parce que moi vous me donnez
deux minutes
deux carrés de sucre une baguette de
pain racine je vous fais avouer
n'importe quoi pourquoi pourquoi
une baguette de pain je vous montrerai
ça merci non merci non la torture
la torture
enfin moi j'ai j'ai aucun doute j'ai
aucun doute et
mon corps plus de valeur d'officier fait
que cette chose là est hors la loi
dans le principe on l'a fait nous on l'a
déjà fait en Algérie mais moi j'étais
pané non mais c'est tout ça oui on l'a
fait dans l'histoire on l'a fait mais
j'étais pas né donc posez posez-moi des
questions sur ce que j'ai fait et je
vais vous dire ce que j'ai fait en
matière de de population détenue ou de
rétention d'abord dans mon corps plus de
valeur ce truc là est hors la loi voilà
et puis ensuite il y a la vie qui rentre
là dedans mais c'est un truc c'est
interdit c'est illégal voilà
quand on était quand on était en
Afghanistan
quand on est sur un théâtre d'opération
extérieure
il y a parfois on fait prisonnier des
gens on va pas les ramener en France en
Afghanistan les gens qu'on et donc il
faut les remettre à quelqu'un il faut
remettre à quelqu'un qui doit les
internets et qui doit les juger
la plupart du temps quand on est sur un
territoire d'opérations sur un théâtre
d'opérations nos diplomates ou la
diplomatie française
s'il y a un accord avec le pays haute
dans lequel le pays haute s'engage à ne
pas mettre en oeuvre la peine de mort et
à ne pas pratiquer de trucs dégradants
etc etc et donc en Afghanistan il faut
pas envoyer Julien Vincent aux
États-Unis par exemple et on Afghanistan
l'État afghan a refusé de signer ça
il a refusé de signer un accord avec
nous et donc quand on faisait des
opérations on était on était bien
ennuyés de savoir ce qu'on faisait des
prisonniers quand il y avait des
prisonniers et donc il y avait deux
solutions
qui étaient pas tout aussi hypocrite
mais
c'était avoir des américains avec nous
parce que les Américains avaient un
accord et donc c'est pas nous qu'ils ont
les prisonniers c'était les Américains
les Américains gérés et puis la deuxième
solution c'est d'avoir avec nous des
Afghans et c'était les Afghans qui les
faisaient prisonniers donc c'était pas
notre affaire tout ça est quand même
très hypocrite et pas très respectueux
mais 2,5% comme je voulais tout à
l'heure et donc quand on a été engagé à
Serval quand on s'est engagé à Serval on
était tout seul c'était nous un peu les
Américains de la zone c'est c'était nous
quitions qui ont tous les effectifs tous
les moyens etc et
friteries et la climatisation sauf ça je
vous raconterai ensuite ça c'était très
drôle et donc on a fait des prisonniers
et donc on se demandait comment on va
gérer ses prisonniers et on voulait pas
faire comme on avait fait en Afghanistan
et on voulait faire un truc propre et on
voulait pouvoir se regarder en disant on
fait bien les
et donc on a créé un centre de rétention
à Gao
avec des gens qui étaient des
professionnels
mais avec des gens qui étaient des
professionnels de la gestion des
prisonniers mais mais parce qu'on ne
voulait pas que ces travers on a donné
la clé
du bâtiment entre guillemets au CICR et
on a dit nous on fait ça et vous venez
quand vous voulez et vous nous dites ce
qui va pas et vous nous dites comment on
doit faire et ensuite à chaque fois
qu'on avait un doute parce qu'il était
jeune parce qu'il était pas majeur etc
on faisait venir le CICR et le HR qui
nous disait c'est un enfant soldat vous
devez le remettre on le remettait etc et
à chaque fois que que on transmettait
les gens après les avoir on les
interroge pas parce qu'il y a une
connotation bizarre mais après avoir eu
un entretien conversationnel avec eux
et donc on les transmettait aux
autorités maliennes en présence des
Nations Unies du HR et du CICR donc on a
fait les choses extrêmement proprement
et donc la torture c'est
de sommeil non non avec la musique
non pas de comment s'appelle le système
de baignade là la serpillière pleine
d'eau alorsing waterboarding
au courant de ça un jour je vais poser
la question Benoît Hamon
il fait semblant de pas connaître
waterboarding ouais
vendredi soir comme ça attaque non non
et donc et donc
vous avez déjà fait une grève de la fin
non combien de temps vous allez arrêter
de manger au maximum
j'ai fait pas une grève de la fin
mais j'étais instructeur à Saint-Cyr et
j'ai accompagné
une partie de la promo qui faisait le
stage jungle au feu ça s'appelle le feu
le centre
équatorial le centre je sais pas quoi de
formation de forêt équatoriale centre
d'entraînement à la forêt équatoriale et
donc là
et donc là vers la fin du stage on est
en pirogue
on est au milieu je sais pas comment
s'appelle la rivière ils nous disent
débarquer mais on est au milieu de l'eau
qui vous balance dans l'eau on rejoint
le temps bien que mal la berge on a deux
allumettes un coupe coupe etc et on
passe trois jours trois jours et on a
deux on a deux cartouches on a un fusil
à pompe et on a deux cartouches et on
passe trois jours à 25 forêt on mange
pas beaucoup
trois jours ça va
croyant Dieu
oui
est-ce que c'est nécessaire quand on est
militaire de croire en quelque chose
oui
quand on est militaire
je sais pas si c'est quand on est
militaire en tout cas en tout cas on
trouve on trouve la consolation on
trouve le discernement
c'est des choses qui sont importantes
quand on quand on rentre en soi sur un
certain nombre de choses et alors pas
non plus
il y a une chose il y a une chose dont
je me souviens très bien où j'ai pas
appelé à l'aide mais où je me suis
tourné vers lui
c'était à la fin de la crise en Côte
d'Ivoire en 2011 vous vous souvenez de
cette affaire là
Bagbo avait refusé le résultat des
élections il y avait des mercenaires
partout dans Abidjan et et on avait reçu
l'ordre on avait reçu l'ordre
confirmé par les Nations Unies
de faire arrêter les massacres que
perpéter les les troubles de Gbagbo
contre la population dans le quartier
d'Abobo qui est un
Adjamé dans le quartier d'Adjamé qui est
un quartier qui est plutôt peuplé par
des gens du Nord etc et donc le mode
d'action on avait des Gazelles avec des
missiles hautes plein de missiles hautes
hélicoptères avec des missiles qui
tirent à 4 km et donc les ordres que
j'étais chef du CPCO et donc les ordres
qu'on avait donné c'est détruire toutes
les toutes les capacités militaires de
Gbagbo donc ces bateaux ces dépôts de
munitions etc sans jamais toucher à sa
résidence où il était où il était claque
muré et donc on fait ça une nuit de nuit
trois nuits 4 nuits avec une pilote
extraordinaire qui qui dormait pas etc
qui volaient revolait enfin bon ça a été
quand même assez exceptionnel et à la
fin on pensait que Gbagbo allait céder
comme ça
et Gbagbo il a passé des on a attiré pas
tous nos missiles mais tout ce qui était
pas cassé était dissimulé et la mission
était pas remplie puisque la mission
c'était permettre aux forces du Nord à
l'Alliance du Nord de pouvoir
s'emparer de Gbagbo et mettre en place
Ouatara qui avait été légitimement élu à
l'occasion de ces élections
et donc là j'ai donné l'ordre en général
qui était sur place
d'y aller à pied quand même difficile
entre tirer à 4 km sur un objectif et
puis fouiller tous les carrefours toutes
les etc et donc ça a été ça a été très
dur ça a été très dur parce qu'on avait
du mal à se comprendre parce que lui il
trouvait que c'était une mission qui
était extrêmement exigeante et donc je
lui dis mais c'est comme ça que tu vas
faire c'est comme ça que tu vas faire
parce qu'il est hors de question que
l'armée française
tourne le dos ou face demi-tour face à
une bande de mecs en claquettes etc et
donc voilà ça a été ça a été compliqué
ça a été un ordre celui qui commandait
était un bon camarade
ça a été très compliqué et je dis c'est
comme ça c'est comme ça et puis ça
faisait moi aussi 3 ou 4000 j'avais pas
dormi parce que je regardais un peu tout
cinéma là et donc je me dis je dis à mon
adjoint
je rentre chez moi je vais prendre une
douche dans deux heures et je reviens
et en partant et en partant j'ai
intercédé en disant mais est-ce que j'ai
eu raison est-ce que est-ce que vous
m'avez donné le discernement de prendre
la décision est-ce que est-ce que j'ai
bien pesé ce que je faisais courir comme
risque au soldat français etc etc etc
autant vous dire que si j'ai pris une
douche j'ai pas dormi et une heure après
je suis revenu avec la tête dans les
épaules le CPCO il fallait descendre
sous terre avec la tête dans les épaules
en me disant mon dieu mon dieu aide-moi
ou mon Dieu pardonne-moi
et quand je suis arrivé pas un soldat
avait été blessé et Gbagbo avait été
fait prisonnier donc oui
un sujet que vous voulez aborder avec
nous pour la prochaine fois
pour une prochaine fois si jamais la
communauté veut encore m'entendre
pérorer pendant des heures alors moi je
vais vous poser la question
c'est pas une question c'est de donner
trois livres à lire à notre communauté
3 livres soit qui vous ont marqué soit
qu'il faut lire absolument soit alors
lire absolument moi j'ai d'abord vous
avez compris que j'étais très attaché à
l'Afrique et je suis très attaché au
désert le désert m'a révélé à moi-même
et je pense que le désert est une
dimension qui est extrêmement importante
et donc si vous demandez trois livres
je vais vous donner trois livres qui
pour moi font partie d'une trilogie même
si jamais ce sont des auteurs différents
et ces trois livres c'est des romans
c'est pas c'est pas là qu'on va
apprendre la guerre et donc je vais vous
proposer je les ai fait lire par
obligation familiale à mes enfants je
vais vous reposer l'Atlantide de Pierre
Benoit
je vais vous proposer l'escadron blanc
de Joseph Perret
et je vous proposais la piste oubliée de
Frison Roche
et ces trois livres ces trois livres qui
racontent des aventures du désert dans
le désert et de la rencontre pas que ça
mais de la rencontre de l'homme et du
désert sinon on peut lire Théodore Monod
et d'autres mais cela c'est des romans
vous lisez ça à la communauté qui dort
pas ou peu va lire ça en une nuit et
c'est des livres qui sont qui sont
passionnants
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations une bouteille à la
mer quelque chose d'intéressable
d'un périssable
ça vient de plus en plus compliqué cet
entretien
qu'est-ce que je peux recommander
moi je pense qu'il faut pas renoncer à
la vérité et il faut pas renoncer à ses
convictions ne pas renoncer à la vérité
ne pas renoncer à ses convictions qui en
coûte
quoi qu'il en coûte quoi qu'il en coûte
quand j'ai dit non pour bombarder cet
immeuble voilà
c'est vous qui me vacciner là c'est vous
qui m'avez
pas mal quoi qu'il en coûte
on se revoit quand
vous me direz ce que pense votre
communauté et on reparlera de ça ah bah
là
ils ont mais what meal question
on est combien en direct là je regarde
on doit être 4000 et des poussières on
est 5167
on vous recontacte on va faire venir
général Didier Castres merci merci à
vous vous êtes le premier à réussir à
avoir accouché comme ça beaucoup ont
essayé personne l'a fait comme comme Sky
merci mon général
[Musique]